Masseglia qui je vous le rappelle a donc
été réélu président du comité national
sportif et olympique français retour à
présent sur un autre temps fort des
travaux de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage avec une table ronde
organisé le 16 mai dernier par les
sénateurs sur le thème dopage et liberté
publique avec entre autres invité Éric
Boyer ancien coureur cycliste de
l'équipe Cofidis et serge Simon
président de proval c'est l'union
syndicale des joueurs de rugby
professionnel table ronde que je vous
propose de suivre tout de
suite nous organisons maintenant une
table ronde sur la lutte contre le
dopage et les libertés
publiques afin de stimuler notre notre
réflexion nous avons en effet souhaité
confronter les points de vue point de
vue des sportifs bien évidemment avec
leurs représentants monsieur Simon pour
les joueurs de rugby monsieur Dutch pour
l'ensemble des joueurs
professionnels ils sont fortement
engagés sur ces problématiques et
présenteront donc un point de vue à la
fois tranché et
éclairant monsieur
Boyer ancien coureur cycliste champion
sera là également pour exprimer son
sentiment sur les règles antidopage il
pourit être bien
différent nous verrons que la lutte
antidopage est parfois une manière très
compllete
et que les curseurs peuvent bouger en
fonction des différents acteurs et
surtout de leurs
expériences sur un tel sujet il fallait
également faire venir des juristes ceux
qui pensent le droit les professeurs
avec Madame BR brune
rosspon ceux qui font vivre le droit
avec les avocats maître Jean-Christophe
Lapouble et ceux qui l'appliquent au
quotidien avec avec Monsieur Olivier
nigli conseiller juridique de Lana Lama
pardon inutile de vous dire que nous
vous remercions tous d'être venus
aujourd'hui nous avons conscience
d'avoir réussi à constituer un groupe
d'intervenants très éminents et qui nous
faudra être attentif pour pouvoir guider
vos débats de manière
pertinente ces débats tourneront autour
de quelques sujets
clés les obligations de géolocalisation
des sportifs seront à priori une
question
centrale le passeport sanguin pourrait
en être une
autre le sujet de la nature des
sanctions notamment l'existence de
sanctions pénales pourrait aussi être
pourrait aussi être abordé vous avez à
cet égard été laissé assez libre de
votre
intervention le format que nous vous
proposons est le
suivant chacun aura au début de cette
réunion 5 minutes pour s'exprimer à
titre liminire un débat d'une heure
environ quelques minutes près aura lieu
ensuite enfin vous terminerez chacun par
une conclusion de 5 minutes c'est le
schéma que nous vous
proposons je rappelle aux personnes qui
assistent à notre
réunion que le silence est nécessaire
pas d'approbation pas de désapprobation
manifeste j'informe aussi les personnes
iitionné que nous sommes dans une
commission d'enquête et nous sommes dans
une une formation de table ronde mais
que pour autant un faux témoignage
devant notre commission pourrait être s
passible de sanction pénale de même la
procédure du serment est tout aussi
impérative alors je vais l'un après
l'autre vous demander de bien vouloir
prêter serment de dire la vérité rien
que la vérité de lever la main droite
après l'autre et de dire je le jure
monsieur charge Simon je commence par
vous parce que c'est la liste qu'on m'a
donné vous
êtes ah pardon
monsieur heureusement qu'ils sont là
parce que Monsieur la pouble d'abord
vous levez s'il vous plaît la main
droite et vous dites je jure je j merci
Monsieur ser Simon c'est à vous
maintenant c'est sûr merci Monsieur
Caston Dodge je jure Monsieur Olivier
Nigl je J monsieur Éric Boyet bonjour et
Madame prune rossipon merci nous en
avons terminé de la première partie
essentielle du serment prêté devant
notre commission
d'enquête je reviens à la formule que je
vous avais proposé vous avez donc
maintenant chacun 5 minutes on va partir
de la gauche vers la droite et on va
essayer de vous faire respecter cette ce
délai de 5 minutes monsieur Lapouble
nous vous
écoutonsés ça attendez bon oui merci
monsieur le Président l'extrême gauche
la parole en premier c'est assez rare
don je plaésente euh je me présente en 5
minutes j'ai fait ma thèse en 93 sur le
dopage et j'avais étudié la loi de 89
qui était la seconde loi sur le dopage à
la première celle de 65 n'a pas
fonctionné euh et et à l'époque on
m'expliquait y compris dans tous les
milieux sportif qui c'était pas un sujet
de thèse puisque il compris quelques
doctes universitaire puisquil y avait
pas de problème il pas de dopog euh où
j'étais tellement fa que c'était pas un
problème et qu'à supposer qu'il existe
il fallait le régler en interne et j'ai
bien peur que malheureusement on en est
toujours un peu là j'ai été inspecteur
Jeunesse et Sport jusqu'en 2000
parallèlement j'ai continué à enseigner
et maintenant je suis effectivement euh
maî de conférence à Scien pour Bordeaux
je dirige la préparation au concours
mais ça c'est accessoire par rapport au
sujet du jour je suis aussi avocat euh
au cabinet Weber à Lyon on est
spécialisé en drit du sport et
j'interviens notamment en matière
sportive et où j'ai eu l'occasion il y a
peu de défendre Christophe basson vous
avez auditionné puisqueeffectivement en
terme de liberté publique lui il a fait
l'objet ce que je dirais d'un contrôle
antidopage inversé mais je vous
expliquerai pourquoi dans le cors de la
discussion euh j'ai aussi à d'autres
titres bon écrit un certain nombre
d'articles sur chaque loi qui est sorti
euh j'ai été expert au près du Conseil
de l'Europe auprès de l'Assemblée
parlementaire en 99 au du Conseil de
l'Europe aussi en 2005 puisque j'ai
écrit le rapport
euh le rapport sur la politique
française au titre du comité de suivi du
Conseil de l'Europe ce qui a donné lieu
d'ailleurs en partie à la loi de 2006 et
j m'est arrivé aussi et ça en présence
d'Olivier nigli de participer à de
missions d'observateur auprès de
l'Agence mondiale antiopage donc voilà à
peu près quelles sont mes activités en
matière de de lutte contre le dopage
donc j'aiess c'est d'écrire et cetera et
évidemment comme avocat il nous arrive
de défendre des sportifs voilà à peu
près rapidement ce que je peux dire
simplement
j'ai avec l'âge maintenant certain recul
j'ai un certain recul et je peux dire
qu'effectivement les choses ont un peu
bougé ce dont je me félicite c'est que
cette commission a été créée puisqueil y
en avait jamais eu d'ailleurs on peut se
poser la
question en 99 mais bon mut tard que
jamais et je pense que et j'espère qu'il
sortira des travaux de cette commission
alors
effectivement un projet de loi qui
pourra permettre dans un environnement
international d'améliorer ce qui existe
sachant que jusqu'à présent j'en
terminerai là-dessus l'impression que
j'enis c'est qu'on a eu àaire à des
couches de peinture successives sans
vision d'ensemble sur sur les effets de
ces couches successives vision
d'ensemble au niveau français mais aussi
compris au niveau international et c'est
un peu le regret que j'ai là-dessus j'en
resterai là
merci Monsieur S
Chimon madame messieurs je vourais
d'abord remercier monsieur le Président
de la Commission du sénateur
Jean-François Humbert et son rapporteur
monsieur Jean-Jacques
losac pour cette invitation et cette
l'existence commission vous verrez que
dans le propos liminire dans mon propos
liminire
je souhaitais depuis longtemps
l'existence de cette commission alors
présentation personnelle je suis médecin
j'ai créé dirigé le CAPS centre
d'accompagnement et de prévention pour
les sportifs au CHU de Bordeaux pendant
10 ans c un centre qui s'occupait des
difficultés psychologiques liées à la
pratique
sportive et à ce titre nous hébergions
la MPD l'antenne médicale de prévention
contre le dopage qui était basé à
Bordeaux donc c'est une question que
j'ai
traité à travers ce service pendant 10
ans je suis aussi également présidente
du syndicat des joueurs de prodie
professionnel et secrétaire général de
la FNAS donc syvin castendel chez le
président alors pour démarrer ce propos
et je vais tenir les temps j'en suis sûr
euh je suis donc médecin ancien sportif
de haut niveau je voudrais dire quelque
chose clairement la lutte antiopage est
nécessaire indispensable que ça soit
bien clair mais mon propos veut lever un
équipproco je pense qu'elle l'est pas
pour les raisons dont elle s'habille et
je vais
développer l'argument qui est souvent
avancé en matière de lutte antiempage
est un argument de santé publique et je
crois qu'on fait fausse route alors
quelques notions de santé publique
peut-être semble nécessaire un problème
de santé publique se définit comme tel
quand il fait peser sur la société un
risque sanitaire et que sont dégagés des
moyens par la puissance publique et des
politiques de puissance publique je vais
donner quelques exemples pour comprendre
que c'est pas une mécanique simple et
que il y a pas une relation de cause à
effet entre l'importance du risque et
l'importance des politiques déployées en
France par exemple le tabac fait 66000
morts par an et des centaines de
milliers de malades ce qu'on appelle la
mortalité d'un côté la morbidité
l'alcool en tu
50000 vous avez ces consommations d'un
côté une autre
consommation beaucoup plus particulière
qui est celle du cannabis qui fait pas
de mort directe mais qui fait dans les
études 230 morts sur les routes donc un
risque objectif sanitaire qui n'a pas de
mesure entre les consommations mais des
politiques sanitaires qui sont
inversement proportionnelles au risque
objectif ce qui en santé publique est
connu c'est-à-dire que la santé publique
n'est pas définie uniquement par un
risque mais par d'autres
facteurs les facteurs sociétaux des
facteurs environnementaux des facteurs
culturels qui font que la consommation
d'alcool dans notre pays est tolérée
voire valorisée ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine culturel donc le risque est
endossé par la société le cannabis qui
n'a pas de risque sanitaire objectif en
tout cas j'ai pas cité la comorbidité du
cannabis c'est aussi un risque sanitaire
c'est-à-dire le fait que la consommation
de cannabis puisse intervenir dans
l'apparition de pathologies mais en tout
cas il n'y a pas cette mesure du risque
que présente l'alcool et le tabac mais
par contre le cannabis pose d'autres
problèmes à la société en terme
d'exemple en terme de pédagogie en terme
évidemment de consommation stupéfiante
et là les politiques sanitaires sont de
l'ordre de la répression puisque l'usage
même du cannabis est est condamnable
c'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est
simplement pour poser ce que peut
définir les politiques de santé publiqu
il n'y a pas une relation de cause à
effet entre le risque sanitaire objectif
et les moyens déployés il y a d'autres
exemples à l'échelle mondiale et je
tiens à les amener un très connu le
paludisme touche 500 millions de
personnes il tue un million de personnes
par an depuis des années ça ne déclenche
pas des politiques sanitaires de
mobilisation mondiale à l'inverse la la
pandémie de hna en 2009 a tué 18500
personnes aux dernières études mais a
déclenché une vague de mobilisation
internationale absolument incroyable là
aussi exemple pour illustrer que à
risque sanitaire objectif il n'y a pas
une relation mécanique par rapport au
moyen de déployer pourquoi parce que
encore une fois
il y a un risque objectif puis un risque
subjectif il y a des lobby il y a des
rapports de force des acteurs de cette
problématique qui vont influencer sur
les politique de santé publique alors si
on définit le le le le le problème de
dopage comme un problème de de santé
publique il obé exactement à la même
mécanique et
on si on essaie d'étudier le risque
sanitaire objectif ça va être très
difficile parce que en fait il n'y a pas
d'études il n'y a pas d'études qui
aujourd'hui en tout cas à ma
connaissance et pour y avoir travaillé
qui puisse mettre en avant la mortalité
ou la morbidité liée aux
consommations d'upante voire même je
vais plus loin il y a pas d'étude qui
puisse dessiner le périmètre de la
consommation d'upante comme il peut y
avoir grâce à l'ofdtofice français de
lutte contre les drogues et
toxicomanie chacun des rapports annuels
sur la consommation de stupéfiants de
tabac d'alcool de cannabis où là il y a
des études qui peut décider qui peut
dessiner le périmètre des consomm
les profils des consommateurs
l'évolution de ces consommations année
après année et ainsi déclencher des
réponses adaptées dans le dopage il n'y
a pas c études il n'y a pas d'étude sur
la morbidité et la mortalité liée au
dopage les seuls chiffres qu'on puisse
avoir ce sont les contrôles antiopage et
si on prend ce de la FLD sur plusieurs
années en gros il il tourne autour des
chiffres suivants c'est 10000 contrôles
par an 200 contrôles
anormaux dont 30 % au cannabis sur les
200 contrôles anormaux il y a pas
d'étude non plus de la de la morbidité
ou de la mortalité alors ce qu'on peut
déduire sur le risque sanitaire objectif
du dopage concrètement et
factuellement c'est que il est très
difficile à Serrier voire impossible et
que s'il existe il a l'air
potentiellement très faible par contre
en face de ça on a une réaction sociale
extrêmement vive donc elle ne s'appuie
pas sur un risque sanitaire objectif je
renvoie à mon raisonnement du début mais
sur d'autres leviers qui sont tout aussi
respectables et tout aussi puissants
mais il faut simplement mettre un petit
peu de lucidité qui sont les leviers
c'est je crois qu'il est facile de
comprendre c'est c'est peut-être on va y
rentrer dans le débat c'est que on
défend tous un idéal sportif que nous
portons en nous avec passion un idéal
sportif qui a des enjeux sociétaux de
modèle pédagogique d'éducation
d'exemplarité et là sont peut-être les
moteurs puissants de la list antidopage
al une fois qu'on a fait ce constat et
qu'on dit que le dopage est un problème
de santé publique comme les autres
finalement qui n'a pas cette mécanique
euh limpide entre le risque sanitaire
objectif et les puissances déployées que
c'est encore une fois quelque chose de
plus de plus complexe mais qu'on est
lucide sur ces choses-là il me semble
que oui c'est quelque chose qui est
important de faire comme constat parce
que euh on doit amener dans la lutte
antidopage une vision euh
réaliste lucide euh essayer d'être
pragmatique d'essayer de sortir d'une
espèce de dictact où justement il y a
énormément d'émotions énormément de de
passion qui impose une espèce de de
cercle vicieux où il y a cette idée que
finalement le sport le sport est touché
de manière extrêmement profonde que tous
les sportifs sont dopés que la lutte
antidopage n'est pas aujourd'hui
efficace comme elle devrait l'être et
l'existence de votre commission à ce
titre est est révélateur et que donc il
y a une
impériosité d'agir de la lite antidopage
sans le temps de la réflexion de
l'étude de l'étude factuelle mais une
espèce de course à la à la à la
répression qui est non pas finalement
une course à l'efficacité mais une
course à la démonstration de la
détermination et dans un angle c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris l'exemple du
cannabis et l'alcool tabac dans dans un
angle où étant donné que le problème est
un non pas un problème sanitaire mais
plutôt un problème d'idéal sportif et
qui est très important encore une fois
structure pour notre société on est
plutôt sur un mode répressif alors
l'argument de santé publique est un
espèce de canal de voie d'habillage mais
qui à mon avis est une est une est une
mauvaise voie et il il faut il faut que
la lutte antiopage devienne plus
raésonné plus pragmatique plus
factuel qu'elle prenne le temps du recul
qu'elle se laisse pas dictter par la
pression médiatique marketing et cetera
et cetera tout ce qui porte l'idéal
sportif pour s'occuper
réellement des sportifs messieurs
mesdames merci merci Monsieur cassandche
oui bonjour merci également pour votre
invitation on est très heureux quand les
sportifs peurvent se faire peuvent se
faire entendre donc je suis Sylvain
castelnch je suis effectivement
président de la FNAS donc qui représente
environ 4000 sportifs professionnels je
suis également co-président de l'UNFP
donc pour les footballeurs
professionnels j'ai été footballeur
professionnel pendant 19 ans et j'ai été
accessoirement adjint en mer de de la
ville de mes chargée des sports et de la
jeunesse voilà donc la FNAS il y a
effectivement CIN cinq disciplines
sportives qui sont qui sont adhérentes
donc Serge avec le le rugby et proval il
y a également l'AND baleur avec la JPH
le basket avec le SNB le
cyclisme avec l'UNCP et donc l'UNFP pour
le foot voilà pour la présentation mon
propos enfin mon préambule sera comment
charpenter autour de quatre quatre
points hein je vais rentrer dans le vif
du sujet donc le premier point et là je
vais me
répéter par rapport à Serge mais en tout
cas évidemment que c'est mieux en le
disant la lutte nécessaire contre le
dopage hein j'y reviendrai j'y
reviendrai après donc la FNAS et les
sportifs qu'elle représent sont
évidemment favorables à une lutte
intensive contre ce fléo hein ne se
méprennent pas il faut même renforcer
cette lutte de manière plus intelligente
hein j'y reviendrai également moins de
localisation individuelle dans les
SPORTCO et plus de contrôle sur les
lieux d'entraînement et de compétition
Serge le disais l'importance des
contrôles effectués depuis 3 ans démonte
que la lutte bas son plein puisque les
chiffres en 2009 il y a eu 100 10130
contrôles en 2010 il y en a eu 10500 et
en 2011 9500 les sportc ont pris
largement leur part dans cette dans ces
dans ces chiffres là et dans ces
contrôles là puisque le foot par exemple
a été contrôlé à 569 reprise et que le
rugby à 428 reprises en 2011 donc voilà
il y a et en rapport combien je pose la
question combien de cas de dopage avéré
donc voilà ça c'était contre la lutte
nécessaire contre le dopage en deuxème
euh on a écouté et préparé enfin on a
écouté attentivement les les les
auditions précédentes et de ces
auditions ressortent quelques remarques
de notre part ou en tout cas on a envie
de de rappeler certaines vérités aux
membres de la commission euh notamment
un point qui doit être expliquer plus
clairement car il est toujours source de
confusion dans l'esprit du grand public
une infraction à la législation
antidopage ou des résultats d'analyse
anormaux ne signifie pas cas de dopage
avéré je crois que c'est important de le
de le souligner il est tout aussi
important de lutter ici contre un
préjugé de certains sénateurs on a
entendu notamment monsieur
nerry affirmeré à plusieurs reprises ù
pensant en tout cas que les sporco ne
souhaitent pas subir hein de contrôle
inopiné on veut là aujourd'hui affirmer
que c'est faux à 100 % hein c'est pas du
tout l'objet de notre de notre bataille
vous allez le comprendre au fil de ce
débat bien au contraire hein on est on
est totalement en faveur de ces
contrôles inopinés on souhaite qu'il se
passe sur le lieu de travail pas au
domicile voilà nos joueurs passent en
moyenne 8 à 10 he par jour dans les
clubs entre les entraînements les soins
et les repas ça donne largement la place
et le temps pour autant de contrôle
inopiné souhaité ça c'est un des axes
importants de notre hein de de de de de
nos propositions vous les verrez vous
les verrez à la fin il est il est pas
tolérable non plus que pour les sportifs
d'entendre le directeur des contrôles de
la FLD donc monsieur Verdi dire qu'il
aimerait et je le cite faire plus de
contrôle sur les animaux car j'aime bien
il le dit hein il aime bien les animaux
et eux au moins ils ne peuvent pas dire
non on a été choqué par cette par cette
affirmation parce que donc apparemment
pour Monsieur Verdi tout doit être
acceptable pour un sportif y compris de
ne pouvoir s'opposer à une
réglementation et de n'avoir d'autre
choix que de lui donner son consentement
ba pas plus que ne sont acceptables les
contrôles pour ciblag tels qu'ils ont
été expliqués par Monsieur jeunevois
pour lesquels se pose un problème de
légalité dans la mesure où le décret qui
doit les mettre en œuvre n'est toujours
pas adopté et que le groupe de travail
mis en place sur la question peine à
communiquer sur les
travaux le président de la fédération de
l'athlétisme également qui se permet de
proposer comme solution à la triche dans
le sport la levée du secret
médical sportifs ne sont pas à ce qu'on
à ce qu'on sache des citoyens de seconde
zone ou en tout cas ne veulent pas le le
devenir à travers ces à travers ces ces
mesures avec aucun respect de de leur
vie privé et puis enfin sur ces sur ces
remarques là par rapport aux précédentes
auditions on a entendu le président de
l'IRB hein sur la sur le côté spécifique
du sport avec le traité de Lisbonne qui
affirmait que notamment la question des
calendriers hein devait ce calendrier
des compétitions devait se régler à
travers cette spécificité nous on pens
au contraire que cette que cette
question éminemment importante
dans l'activité des des sportifs et du
sport en général doit être réglé par les
partenaires sociaux au sein de chaque
discipline c'est ce qui commence à se
faire mais qui est encore insuffisant
voilà nous on pense vraiment que ça doit
être réglé entre les acteurs du sport
voilà le trisième petit petit chapitre
donc c'est c'est directement on est
contre le système actuel de localisation
à la charge des sportif dans les
disciplines collectives je m'explique en
2011 la FLD a développé un nouveau mode
de contrôle 2500 68 prélèvements pour le
profilage ont été réalisés sur un total
de 1648 sportifs 75 profils anormaux
parmi des sportifs ont pu être mis en
évidence mais aucune sanction juste une
information auprès du médecin des
fédérations pour indiquer les anomalies
deuxièmement ce sont les prémisses du
passeport biologique hein qui ne pourra
être mis en place qu'à partir du 1er
juillet 2013 là aussi je vous rappelle
que les données font l'objet d'un
traitement statistique âge sexe
discipline historique d'exposition à des
altitudes élevées et qu'il faudra être
vigilant parce qu'à priori donc la knil
n'a pas rendu d'avis encore là-dessus
le principe de localisation tel que
pratiqué par la FLD n'a rien apporté à
la lutte contre le dobage hormis
quelques sportifs n fautif anormalement
suspendu pour trois nochau on a des
exemples
célèbres ensuite le dispositif du groupe
cible est particulièrement intrusif
pardon puisqu'il commande au sportifs
concerné donc là je démontre un petit
peu la mécanique he vous la connaissez
mais bon c'est toujours mieux quand même
en le disant donc sans qu'ils aient
donné leur accord on en revient à ce que
disait tout à l'heure monsieur monsieur
Verdi au sportifs concernés donc de
communiquer à F pour le trimestre àenir
des informations sur leur lieu de
résidence d'entraînement et de
compétition de façon à pouvoir être
localisable à tout moment et de se
soumettre sur le champ au divers
contrôles ordonnés discrétionnairement
par l'agence le principe d'égalité entre
tous les sportifs n'existe plus puisque
seuls les joueurs désignés comme membres
du groupe cible sont assujettis à ce
devoir de localisation laissant certains
sous l'emprise d'un régime d'exception
où le sportif est un suspect potentiel
enfin le sportif localisable va se
trouver soumis à une surveillance
permanente l'affectant nécessairement
dans sa vie quotidienne et portant ainsi
atteinte à ses relations avec sa famille
et son entourage proche une telle
obligation abouti en fait à priver le
sportif de la possibilité de répondre à
un événement imprévu de se déplacer de
façon spontanée et donc juste d'avoir
une vie familiale normale cette atteinte
à la vie familiale se comprend d'aut au
moins que le sportif professionnel se
voit soumis déjà à de nombreuses
contraintes pour les besoins de son
métier il est notamment amené à
travailler le weekend ou encore à
quitter son domicile dans le cadre de
déplacement sur les lieux de compétition
à se rendre en stage en sélection bref à
renoncer à une vie familiale classique
il ne lui reste que de rares moments
pendant les il peut mener une vie
familiale normale je suis toujours sur
les sporco hein attention que nous soit
ici rapportter la preuve de la
proportionnalité sergeen parlais des
mesures imposées aux sportifs quand les
statistiques ne mentionnent qu'un infime
pourcentage d'infraction les moyens
utilisés sont-ils donc toujours
pertinents nous pensons que non pourquoi
l'éthique l'équité et la santé publique
ne devrait concerner que les sportifs
professionnels aujourd'hui aucune autre
catégorie professionnelle justement quel
que soit le statut de ses membres
l'importance ou la dangerosité des
missions qui lui sont confiées n'est
soumise à des obligations aussi
intensives et aussi intrusives quelques
exemples les militaires qui utilisent
des armes de guerre les médecins qui ont
la vie de leur passion entre leurs mains
les pilotes d'avion qui sont
responsables de centaines de passagers
les capitaines d'industrie et cetera les
opérateurs de marché dans l'activité
financière est considérable voilà aucune
autre catégorie n'est soumise à ces à
ces
intrusions je parle pas des
représentants du peuple Français qui
sont appelés à décider parfois du sort
de leur citoyens sur ce donc nous
aimerions rappeler ici que plusieurs
actions contentieuses sont actuellement
pendantes par l'intermédiaire des
sportifs la première devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme visant
à contester l'ordonnance du 14 avril
2010 sur le principe de localisation
permanente puis une deuxième devant la
Cour de cassation avec demande de QPC
sur la reconnaissance des multiples
violations au droits de la personne
causé par ce principe de localisation je
crois que je me réserverai les
propositions pour pour la
conclusion monsieur Nigl
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur d'abord au nom de laama merci
de m'avoir invité à participer à cette
discussion euh deux mots de présentation
je suis avocat je suis le conseil
juridique de Lama depuis 14 ans à ce
titre j'ai participé à l'élaboration du
code mondial antidopage à sa révision en
2009 et aux travaux en cours sur la
révision du code qui qui ont lieu en ce
moment
alors en introduction je je vais me
concentrer sur les deux thème que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure à savoir la
localisation et le passeport euh pour
peut-être donner un petit contexte
historique sur la façon dont les choses
se sont passées dans la lutte contre le
dopage et et pour dire que le principe
de localisation dans la première version
du
code était reconnu mais sans volonté
d'harmoniser le système c'est-à-dire que
le code laissait à chaque fédération le
soin de gérer ce principe de
localisation comme il l'entendait euh
c'est certains sports avaient l'habitude
d'avoir une localisation par exemple le
cyclisme de façon d'ailleurs bien plus
contraignante que ce qui existe
aujourd'hui puisque le cyclisme à
l'époque demandait d'une localisation 7
jours sur 7 24 he sur 24 ce qui n'est
plus du tout le cas
aujourd'hui sans que finalement dans ces
sports là cela a posé de grands
problèmes à ma connaissance il y a eu
une décision judiciaire en Espagne sur
cette question qui a d'ailleurs reconnu
la nécessité euh de ce système et sa
proportionnalité comp tenue de son but
en dehors de ça je pense que dans ces
sports-là il y avait une certaine
reconnaissance de la part des sportif de
la nécessité de cette localisation
notamment pour effectuer des contrôles
inopinés euh et pour lutter de façon
efficace contre le
dopage lorsque la le code a été révisé
euh et les travaux ont eu lieu dans les
années 2007 environ pour une entrée en
vigueur en 2009 clairement euh il y a la
nécessité d'avoir une situation
harmonieque qui permettrait de
reconnaître d'un sport à l'autre et
d'une agence nationale à une fédération
les tests manqués s'est fait sentir et
c'est à ce moment-là que l'AMA est
intervenu pour harmoniser le système
dans ce cadre là une vaste un vaste
processus de consultation a été mis en
place
et je dirais que à l'issue de ce
processus
c'est le standard minimum acceptable par
tous qui a été mis en place à savoir
l'exigence pour les sportifs de donner
une heure par jour entre 6h du matin et
23h pendant laquelle il pourrait être
contesté quand je dis les sportifs des
groupes de sportifs
identifiés qui concernaient et qui
devaient concerner disons les sportifs
d'élite alors il y a peut-être eu ici ou
là certaines agences nationales qui ont
été plus élé que d'autres mais en règle
générale cela devait concerner
véritablement les sportif qui
présentaient un risque et qui était
concerné lorsque le système a été
harmonisé c'est là que on peut dire
qu'une certaine polémique a eu lieu pas
tellement autour du système qui comme je
l'ai dit était déjà existant depuis
longtemps mais parce que certains sports
qui n'étaient pas concernés qui
n'avaient rien en place se sont trouvés
confrontés à cette réalité que d'autres
connaissaient déjà notamment les sports
collectifs mais pas uniquement d'autres
sports individuels aussi ont découvert
ce système et ça ça a créé un certain
nombre de discussions au final le
système a été relativement bien accepté
il y a une décision du Conseil d'État
que vous connaissz qui a reconnu la
validité du système il y a un appel
pendant à la cour européne des droits de
l'homme on verra ce que ça donne mais
dans l'ensemble euh je pense qu'il y a
une reconnaissance globale de la
nécessité d'avoir une localisation si
l'on veut faire des tests hors
compétition or tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que les tests hors compétition sont
quand même le seul moyen finalement de
faire des tests efficaces les tests en
compétition étant quand même très
prévisiblebles mon 2ième point qui fait
le lien entre la localisation et le
passeport euh c'est que le système du
passeport de la alè et des profils que
ce soit sanguin ou probablement l'avenir
urinaire se base sur un profil dans le
temps et que les éléments de
localisation sont indispensables à
l'établissement d'un passeport d'une
part pour pouvoir effectuer des
contrôles de nouveau au bon moment par
rapport à un profil il faut un mélange
de test en et hors compétition pour
avoir un profil qui permette d'avoir un
sens mais également pour que les experts
lorsqu'ils sont amenés à réviser un
profil
sanguin puisse avoir accès finalement à
l'emploi du temps aux activités de
l'athlète parce que analyser par exemple
des variations sanguines
euh les éléments de compétition le
calendrier des compétitions le
calendrier du repos les périodes où
potentiellement il aurait été utile de
retirer du sang si on voulait se le
réinjecter plus tard tous ces élémentsl
doivent être prise en compte et mise en
parallèle avec le profil sanguin donc de
nouveau les éléments de localisation
sont indispensable à une analyse
intelligente du passeport alors voilà je
crois que je ne vais pas aller plus loin
dans mon introduction juste pour dire
que je crois que ce système est
aujourd'hui demandé par beaucoup
d'athlètes qui veulent savoir que
lorsqu'ils seront sur la ligne de départ
ils seront dans un environnement propre
et relativement bien accepté notamment
au niveau juridique merci merci monsieur
Éric
Boyet ça bonjour madame messieur
monsieur le Président messieurs les
rapporteurs je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité à participer à cette table ronde
donc voilà je vais me présenter donc
Éric Boyet j'ai donc été courur cycliste
de 1985 à
1985 ensuite Lure de la reconversion à
sonné j'ai donc étais consultant puis
organisateur de de compétition pour
finir par diriger une équipe cycliste
professionnelle donc donc de 2005 à à
2012 h la raison pour laquelle j'avais
été donc recruté en 2005 par l'équipe
Cofidis c'est venait suite à des grandes
grandes problèmes de de dopage en 2004
de l'équipe cyclis cophidis et ma
mission première était
de redonner la possibilité à tous les
coururs de cette équipe
d'évoluer dans le pleuton sans jamais
évidemment avoir cours au dopage donc
mon travail m'a amené à constater
euh les les les problèmes que
rencontraient les courur cyclistes pour
mener à bien leur
carrière face à la difficulté qu'ils
avaient donc de rivaliser avec un
beaucoup trop de cours qui euh encore
pratiquaient le dopage et à ce titre
j'ai pu donc constater euh l'échec total
de l'Union Cycliste Internationale quant
à la lutte contre le le dopage on peut
le le remarquer face euh quand
on relit les déclarations de de les
Armstrong j'ai été aussi donc confronté
à certains de mes homologues collègues
dirigeants managers d'équipe et j'ai là
aussi pu constater la connivance qui
existait entre certains d'entre eux et
euh
l'UCI ça a été c'était V quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel de
pouvoir remarquer à quel point il y
avait une complicité dans la politique
mené par l'UCI et par certains
dirigeants d'Équipe et malheureusement
parfois j'aiété constaté enfin obligé de
constater qu'il y avait euh
euh des comment dirais une politique
commune mais qui était qui n'allait pas
du tout dans le sens de la la lutte
contre contre le dopage
euh mon métier aussi m'a amené à
constater euh le travail de certains
médecins d'équipe services médicaux de
trop d'équipe euh n'était pas là pour
euh la protection de la santé des
coureurs ils étaient là pour la
performance
euh il ils exerçaient une certaine
pression auprès des coureurs
euh pression
insupportable uniquement basé sur la
performance et j'ai pu aussi constater
malheureusement le gain financiers que
ces médecins pouvaient obtenir face à la
performance des coureurs c'était
vraiment quelque chose d'insupportable
d'insupportable
quand d'autres dirigeants d'Équipe
justement avec une seule et unique
mission la protection de la santé de
leur coureurs évidemment puisqu'on était
on est dans un monde de compétition
sportive et ben de tenter d'exister de
gagner des courses des compétitions dans
dans sur ce terrain-là dans ce milieu-là
euh donc la responsabilité des de
médecins d'équipe est très engagé dans
la lutte contre le dopage et là encore
une fois on peut que constater l'échec
ensuite par rapport au au sujets qui
nous intéresse effectivement la
géolocalisation les courur cyclistes ont
été les premiers à inaugurer donc cette
cette géolocalisation certes c'est pas
simple ça a été très compliqué au début
très comment
dirais-je
contraignant il y a eu des améliorations
de de réaliser en effet mais je vais
vous faire constater que à quel point
tout de même les corcyclistes ont adhéré
à cette géolocalisation ont accepté de
s'y soumettre ne serait-ce que pour
démontrer que ils étaient prêts eux à
euh faire tout leur possible pour pour
lutter contre contre le dopage ensuite
par rapport au au Passeport sanguin oui
c'est quelque chose qui est très
intéressant et qui a peut-être pas
encore porté t tous ses fruits dans la
lutte contre le dopage mais il faut
faire plus que ça le passeport sanguin
ne suffit pas il faut mettre en place à
mon avis un passeport
physiologique parce queun athlète il il
a des il a des capacités naturelles
génétique il peut évidemment progresser
par son travail son
entraînement mais il a ses limites et
ces limites elles sont euh assez à mon
avis mais évidemment sur un terrain je
suis pas médecin mais elles sont à mon
avis assez faciles à contrôler on peut
progresser on peut évoluer mais on peut
pas passer du jour au lendemain à
euh une 50e place 60 e place sur un tour
de France à finir dans les 5 premiers
c'est pas possible donc le passeport
physiologique permettrait véritablement
de suivre l'athlète tout au long de sa
carrière et de en fonction de son
évolution de sa progression vérifier si
tout ça est réalisé dans les règles
voilà je vous
remercie madame brun
rcipon bonjour euh monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur messieurs euh je
vous remercie de de m'avoir également
invité à cette à cette commission
quelques mots pour pour me présenter euh
donc je suis juriste euh je travaille
pour le Centre de droit et d'économie du
sport de Limoge euh à ce titre je fais
essentiellement du du conseil juridique
par le biais d'un d'un cabinet d'avocat
euh aux institutions sportives donc les
fédérations et et les ligues
professionnelles euh notamment en
matière de dopage puisque c'est un des
domaines dans lequels je suis
spécialisée euh cela essentiellement
parce que j'ai travaillé euh auparavant
pour le ministère de la Jeunesse et des
Sports euh sous la direction de de
Sophie Chayer que vous avez d'ailleurs
auditionné euh et j'ai notamment été
chargé de de rédiger les décrets
d'application de de la loi de 2006 euh
notamment en matière disciplinaire avec
le le précédent règlement disciplinaire
type euh je suis par ailleurs euh
également c'est pareil avec Monsieur
monsieur Lapouble je j'écris beaucoup
dans dans ce domaine notamment dans dans
la revue JuriSPORT que nous publions au
CDES je suis également l'auteur de la de
l'étude lutte contre le dopage au aux
éditions législative au dictionnaire
permanent droit du sport et euh par
ailleurs je suis euh présidente de la
commission de discipline euh lutte
contre le dopage de la Fédération
Française de Gymnastique euh je suis
également présidente de la commission de
révision antidopage de la Fédération
internationale de skin montagne et je
suis inspecteur disciplinaire à l'UFA
euh il s'agit de de faire les
instructions disciplinaires en matière
de manière générale mais également en
matière de dopage donc voilà pour vous
montrer un peu la la palette des des
champs dans lequel j'interviens
euh sur sur cette question de de la
lutte contre le dopage et en en
introduction je pense qu'on va essayer
de de passer très rapidement au débat
euh je je reviendrai pas sur le constat
qu'on a qu'on a tous fait ici qui est de
dire que évidemment le dopage est un
fléo et qu'il convient de de lutter
contre contre ce
fléo je pense qu'il est important de de
préciser que que la nature du dopage le
dopage aujourd'hui est vraiment quelque
chose de d'assez structurel et que il
faut pas il faut pas envisager ça de de
manière comme une problématique
individuelle
finalement la la seconde chose que
j'aurais voulu préciser et je pense que
c'est vraiment important que que
Monsieur nigli soit là aujourd'hui c'est
que la la lutte contre le dopage a
vraiment une dimension internationale je
crois que ça a été également mentionné
par mes par par mes prédécesseurs c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental on
peut pas envisager la lutte contre le
dopage au sur un point de vue
strictement
franco-français et c'est important de
prendre en compte à la fois la
réglementation de l'Agence mondiale
antidopage mais également ce qui se
passe au niveau européen union
européenne conseil Conseil de l'Europe
sur les euh sur les fondements de la
lutte contre le dopage euh monsieur
Simon a a parlé
de de la santé publique et j'avoue que
je serais assez euh d'accord avec avec
son son propos euh qui est de dire que
la la santé publique ne peut pas
justifier à elle seule en tout cas euh
l'ensemble de la lutte contre l' doopage
et euh et de mon point de vue c'est euh
c'est quelque chose qui s'imbrique
également donc santé publique certes euh
mais également protection de l'intégrité
des compétitions de l'éthique du sport
on revient sur sur la valeur
d'exemplarité du sport alors pour euh
pour venir sur la question qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement
aujourd'hui sur le le dopage et les
libertés publiques euh finalement la
question euh à laquelle on va devoir
répondre ou en tout cas à laquelle on
est sur laquelle on doit discuter et de
savoir jusqu'à quel point finalement on
peut porter atteinte aux libertés publi
au nom de cette nécessaire lutte contre
le dopage ce qui pose aussi des
questions et c'est également ce que ce
qu' ce dont a parlé monsieur Simon sur
la question de l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage actuellement et et
forcé de de constater que l'efficacité
actuellement de la lutte contre le
depage est pas forcément avéré et que à
ce titre on peut on peut se demander
vers quel futur il faut aller euh pour
la lutte contre le dopage voilà je vous
remercie merci à vous
madame on
va demander au rapporteur de vous poser
la première question et on essaiera de
donner la parole à tout le monde pour
que vous puissiez répondre aux questions
qui seront
posées bien merci à vous toutes et à
vous tous notamment pour votre présence
à nos côtés ce matin donc on va essayer
de de structurer un peu nos nos débats
nos échanges mais avant d'entrer dans
dans le vif du sujet à vous entendre et
les uns et les autres notamment parce
qu'il y a ici des des représentants des
des pratiquants des des des syndicats de
de sportifs sport collectif sport
individuel même si Mons Boyer n'est pas
la tête d'un syndicat représentant les
les courur cyclistes et tout en sachant
qu'il y a également une approche
juridique à ce problème c'est je dirais
la question de la gouvernance la
question de du fonctionnement des
relations entre les différents acteurs
du du milieu sport
sur tout un ensemble de sujets
essentiels dont le dopage fait partie
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que la la
réalité pardon la réalité je dirais du
du dialogue social he notamment entre
employeur et
employés la réalité des des politiques
contractuelles par rapport à tout un
ensemble de sujets et notamment la
question de la défense des droits du
travail des sportifs eux-mêmes est-ce
que vous pensez que cet aspect là
aujourd'hui est satisfaisant euh dans
euh le fonctionnement interne au sport
français ou est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut aller encore beaucoup plus loin
dans les échanges la concertation les
propositions euh et cetera c'est une
question d'ordre général euh qui vous
concerne directement puisque vous
représentez les sportifs eux-même mais
avec aussi je crois une dimension
juridique est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
est en avance ou en retard par rapport
aux autres pays ou par rapport aux
autres corps de métier tout simplement
alors qui commence je vais je vais me
lancer oui ça va pas être long et pour
répondre très directement à votre
question dans la mesure où justement
tout repose sur le sportif toutes les
obligations les sanctions reposent sur
le sportif je vais carécaturer mais je
vais dire que les employeurs
s'en s'en occupent pas c'estàdire que le
dialogue social sur cette question là
n'existe pas c'est je pourra témoigner
au niveau du rugby moi je vais parler du
foot puisque je suis en même temps je
vous dis co-président de l'UNFP donc euh
que ce soit dans les différents conseils
d'administration de la LFP donc de la
Ligue euh au niveau de la Fédération
c'est pareil la voie des sportifs n'est
évidemment pas prise en compte et je
vous dis elle est pas prise en compte
parce que justement euh les employeurs
je pense qu'ils font pas un bon calcul
mais les employeurs en tout cas euh ne
ne ne veulent pas ne veulent pas en tout
cas euh euh contribuer euh comme on
comme comme on le pense nous à améliorer
justement cette lutte contre le contre
le dopage
le dialogue n'existe pas les débats
n'existent pas je vous dis les sportifs
se débrouillent ils sont seulement
intéressés et concerné le jour où le
sportif est sanctionné alors là
effectivement il y a des levées de
bouclier il y a de l'agitation
médiatique mais en tout cas rien n'est
fait ni avant ni après pour tenter
justement de de nous accompagner sur nos
convictions alors ils nous le disent
comme
ça pas officiellement et il nous
encourage en effet à à à faire entendre
notre notre voix mais en tout cas il y a
rien de il y a rien qui est fait
officiellement en tout cas au niveau de
ces instances là merci ser
Chimon quel question monsieur losac elle
est vraiment extrêmement intéressante
mais je pense qu'elle pourrait faire
l'objet d'une are commission d'enquête
parlementaire je vais être aussi très
courtéch dans ma dans ma dans ma
réponse le dialogue social est nul dans
le sport français et international nul
l'organisation du sport est une
organisation qui date de 100 ans qui est
très simple à comprendre en illustrant
par des exemples vous avez des
fédérations dans lesquelles vous avez
des dirigeants à 100 % je prendre
l'exemple de la Fédération française de
rugby vous n'avez pas de place pour la
parole des pratiquants au qu'un dialogue
social vous avez un représentant des
joueurs qui est coopté comme dans tous
les organismes internationaux de
sportifs comme à la main c'est-à-dire on
va choisir un athlète qui est finalement
un futur dirigeant mais qui représente
qui n'a pas la légitimité de la
représentativité qui qui qui est
certainement pertinent sympa tout ce que
vous voulez mais ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas du tout du dialogue donc dans toutes
les fédérations vous avez ces comités
d'écteurs où il n'y a pas de place en
tout cas statutairement réservé à la
représentation des pratiquants ce qui
est hallucinant puisque c'est nous qui
faisons tout hein il il en est de même
dans un comité directeur de la Ligue
nous avons une voix sur sur 13 et où
finalement on pèse rien rien alors
sommes-nous en retard par rapport à
d'autres pays oui bien sûr on peut
prendre d'exemple le sport pro est
beaucoup plus développé en tout cas sur
un autre modèle c'est les États-Unis où
là ce n'est que du dialogue social entre
employeur et employé et où effectivement
tout se discute jusqu'au calendrier
jusqu'au format des compétitions et et
et on aspirerait alors peut-être pas les
jusque là parce que c'est un autre
modèle culturel il s'agit pas de faire
un copier-collé mais que le sport sorte
de cette de fonctionnement
dictatorial qui sport qui est censé
incarner la démocratie les valeurs
républicaines et cetera et cetera et
cetera
où les pratiquants n'ont aucune aucune
aucune place pour leur parole deuxième
remarque elle est très courte la place
de la parole des pratiquants dans ce
sujet particulier du dopage est très
complexe pourquoi parce que comme on
l'entend et vous l'avez certainement
entendu lors de toutes ces auditions et
bien le sportif c'est un présumé
coupable c'est à la fois c'est une
victime parce qu'on voudrait le protéger
de quoi de lui-même mais à la fois c'est
le Coupat puisque c'est lui qui agit en
en potentiel donc sa parole est très
suspecte je je je je voudrais rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit au sujet de
la
géolocalisation monsieur nigli se
félicit de l'efficacité de la
géolocalisation des chiffres qui
viennent de la compilation des agences
européennes de lutte antidopage il y a
eu
13738 contrôles par ces agences il y a
eu 222 infraction ça c'est pendant les
compétitions il y a eu
17166 contrôles hors compétition donla
monsieur N
28 infraction je sais pas le pourcentage
que ça fait mais si ça montre une
efficacité thoride de les géologes il
faut il faut nous l'expliquer et la
deuxième remarque sur les propos de é
voyez ces propos sont très intéressants
il parle des cyclistes qui ont dit qui a
dit on a été prêt à s'y soumettre à
cette
géolocalisation parle pas d'efficacité à
si'y soumettre je reprendses propos ne
serait-ce que pour démontrer que nous
voulons tout faire il s'agit bien de
soumission et la démarche de de la
géolocalisation elle est là c'est
montrer aux sportifs qu'ils doivent se
soumettre et comme je vous c'était pour
illustrer ce propos de la parole des
pratiquants est complexes parce que si
vous contredisez si vous levez la main
en disant on est peut-être peut-être un
peu trop loin parce qu'on est d'accord
pour lesôles inopinés mais il y a
peut-être d'autres façons et bien la
simple la simple chose que l'on voit
c'est que vous ne voulez pas vous
soumettre et donc vous êtes suspecté
voilà à la
logique merci on a un peu sorti du sujet
toutour des restant mais on j'essayer
d'y revenir il y a aucun problème
monsieur la pouble juste par rapport à
ça par rapport à à ce qui a été dit euh
je pense que il faut avoir une vision
d'ensemble et ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand on dit euh c'est le problème
de santé publique puis non finalement
c'est un problème d'éthique euh la
structuration du sport en France il
vient d'être dit que c'est un modèle
dictatorial je suis je suis au regret de
dire que si on regarde les écrits de
kuoubertin et autres je sais pas qui a
pu voir la démocratie dedans mais
kuoubertin et les autres le modèle
sportif est un modèle je cite un
sociologue alors j'ai plaisanté sur
l'extrême gauche pour le coup lui il est
vraiment marxiste qui s'appelle
Jean-Marie Brom et qui a écrit le sport
est un univers de de règles et de loi et
la structuration du sport a toujours été
un univers où le sportif se
soumettait le problème est à l'heure
actuelle que dans le système français
tant qu'il s'agit de de d'associations
qui n'ont pas de prérogative de
puissance publique on est libre d'en
partir relativement dans le système
français on a donneré d'normes pouvoirs
en Fédération sans être en mesure
d'assurer le contrôle qui va avec et je
pense qu'il y a un véritable problème
quant à la position du sportif sauf que
là le débat part un peu vers les
sportifs professionnels et que
effectivement la question c'est est-ce
que on peut considérer qu'un sportif
amateur un sportif professionnel c'est
la même chose c'est la même position i
je pense qu'il faut avoir un vrai débat
là-dessus le système américain a été a
été montré effectivement l'avantage du
système américain avec un certain nombre
de dérives parce que la National College
atthletic association on sait très bien
que ils sont amateur que assez
ponctuellement ils touchent pas d'argent
en fait ils ont tout ce qui va avec mais
enfin au moins il y a le mérite de la
chose suivante c'est qu'on a un système
professionnel qui ass sur du chaud
j'utilise le terme volonté et puis on a
un système qui reste encore enur dans le
système français on est encore à la
école qui consiste à dire que comm on
joue au football qu'on a le même ballon
on fait la même chose je pense qu'il
faudrait se poser la question
ontologiquement de savoir si c'est la
même chose je pense que non ce qui
indubitablement induit des répercussions
sur la lutte antidopage que l'on assure
et la question a été donné a été abordée
sur les sistes que l'on demande un
certain nombre d'obligations par rapport
à la localisation sur les professionnel
dans la mesure où c'est engadré je suis
pas d'accord avec tout j'ai signé un
article qui s'appelait la localisation
donc un Big Brother sinvite chez les
sportifs donc je suis à l'aise avec ça
mais je pense que ça peut se justifier
si c'est bien encadré sauf que est-ce
qu'on peut la positionner cette
localisation de la même manière chez un
sportif professionnel qui est très bien
payé très bien encadré et chez un tireur
à l'arc qui gagne péniblement sa vie
c'est un autre problème il faudrait
quand même peut-être l'aborder parce que
le sportif professionnel soyons clair il
a les moyens d'échapper à la
localisation je discutais avec Olivier
nigli dans les couloirs d'ici je lu
disais en Afrique vous allez vous passer
vos vacances en Afrique la localisation
vous évitait le représentant de Lama en
Afrique qui qui siège en Afrique du Sud
me disait oui c'est vrai que là on en
est pas là encore on en est pas là hein
donc c'est aussi un problème qui se pose
d'égalité par rapport à la véritable
localisation mais après si vous voulez
sur le poids de l'institution et je vais
rebondir sur ce que disait s Simon moi
j'ai fait l'objet deun nostracisme vous
n'yêtes pour rien mademoiselle je vous
rassure il y avait à mon jury de thèse
François la Philippe qui m'a expliqué
qu'il ferait tout pour me couler hein en
gros et oui et donc je n'ai jamais pu
publier dans dans la dans la revue
juridique économique de limoche
rassurez-vous j'ai survécu hein je suis
un peu la peau durure pourquoi parce
qu'à l'époque à l'époque et bien oui il
y avait des gens qui nous expliquaient
que le dopage ça n'existait pas ça
devait être réglé en interne je suis
ravi de savoir que désormais on prend
globalement le problème dans son
ensemble mais sur l'éthique j'ai un
doute j'ai un doute parce que le
mouvement sportif est ambivalent il a
tendance à dire regardez c'est nos
propres affaires ne venez pas si on
considère que le spor que le le dopage
c'est qu'une pure question d'éthique je
serais tenté de dire l'éthique c'est
personnel c'est interne aux institutions
qu'ell se débrouille c'est vrai pour
autant que c'est pas un problème de
santé publique majeur et je reviendrai
sur une disposition de la loi française
qui me choque profondément c'est
l'obligation qu'un médecin de dénoncer
un sportif nominativement dont il décè
des signes de dopage ce qui honnêtement
juridiquement me fait rire euh pourquoi
parce que si cette obligation qui a été
créée sous Vichy pour les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles pouvez se
comprendre je vais pas vous faire des
détails en matière de dopage c'est pas
contagieux et donc on a depuis la loi 99
ce type de disposition dans la loi
française personne ça l' ému ça me
semble donc on a toute une série de
choses qui sont inadaptées par rapport
au système réel c'estàdire que quel est
le médecin qui va dénoncer à ma
connaissance il en a pas eu mais je
crois qu'il faut avoir une vision
globale et que on peut pas dire le
sportif àamateur le sportif
professionnel c'est la même chose que le
sportif amateur représenter dans une
fédération avec le système tel qu'il
existe à l'heure actuelle et c'est vrai
là-dessus je partage certaines analyses
qui consistent à dire que contrairement
aux élections législative ou sénatorial
mais si les sénateurs dans les
fédérations sportives je peux vous
prédire avec à peu près
99,99 % de nos chances le résultat
l'issu des des élections fédérales c'est
pas le cas pour législative ou pour les
sénatoriales ce qui montre bien que la
démocratie a du progrès à faire et j'en
finirai là-dessus pour cette
intervention merci je dirais au combien
avez-vous raison sur le dernier point
évoqué rien n'est jamais acquis monsieur
nigli
vous monsieur le Président évidemment je
vais pas me prononcer sur la réalité du
dialogue social en France c'est loin de
ma compétence et pas l'intention de
discuter de ça mais par contre peut-être
quand même une ou deux petites remarques
d'abord au niveau de l'Agence mondiale
antidopage nous avons eu un certain
nombre de discussions notamment avec des
syndicats de joueurs dans le casre de la
révision du code mondial on a eu une
séance récemment avec unig global qui
est un des grands syndicats dans ce
domaine-là donc je veux dire il y a
effectivement une discussion et un
dialogue maintenant aujourd'hui ici
autour de la table ronde il vous manque
un acteur parce que euh on parle de
légitimité de la représentativité c'est
ce que monsieur Simon a dit tout à
l'heure mais ici on a des représentants
des sports collectifs euh la réalité du
du sport globalement et à travers la
planète c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
sports qui sont pas représentés
par des
syndicats il y a des institutions où il
y a une élection démocratique de
représentants des athlètes au sein du
Comité olympique et un comité des
athlètes où ce sont les athlètes qui
élisent leurs représentants d'un point
de vue démocratique ça me paraît quand
même relativement légitime voire
peut-être plus légitime que que le
fonctionnement d'un syndicat donc c'est
pas uniquement un dialogue social
entre les syndicats et le monde sportif
il y a beaucoup d'athlètes qui se
sentent pas représentés par leur
syndicat et qui ont envie de faire
entendre leur voix à titre individuel et
ce dialogue il existe aussi avec ces ces
C ces athlètes là notamment par le biais
de ces institutions de ces comités donc
ils sont pas choisis parce qu'ils sont
sympathiques ils sont choisis parce
qu'ils ont été élus par leur par leur
père
euh je me permets une petite digression
monsieur le Président parce qu'il y a eu
une remarque sur les statistiques et je
veux juste clarifier ça parce que sinon
on pourra pas y revenir
euh clairement euh il y a cette étude
statistique dont on a été fait mention
euh et et qui est connu depuis quelques
années maintenant euh montre
effectivement des résultats qui sont
peut-être pas satisfaisants mais la
première constatation c'est que tout le
monde était d'accord les syndicats comme
Lama comme d'autres que les chiffres
disponibles pour faire des statistiques
ne sont pas satisfaisants donc en tirer
des conclusion quand on est tous
d'accord que les chiffres sont pas bons
c'est quand même difficile la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on compte des on compare
des pommes avec des poires parce que
quand on compare des tests en
compétition où la liste des substances
est plus du double de ce qu'elle est
hors compétition il y a une certaine
façon de de de comparer les chiffres on
compare pas la même chose forcément que
les potentiel de résultat positif est
différent dans un test hors compétition
et en compétition donc je pense qu'avec
les chiffres il faut être très prudent
et certainement un des buts c'est d'en
avoir des meilleurs pour pouvoir faire
des
statistiques
merci juste un un petit exemple
effectivement par rapport au au dialogue
social
pardonnez-moi
euh effectivement les sur le terrain les
les athlètes sont trop livrés à
eux-mêmes en effet ils sont là pour
avoir des résultats ils veulent des
résultats finalement ils ont choisi de
pratiquer un sport compétition
professionnelle c'est pour faire
carrière donc par définition faire
carrière c'est avoir des
résultats mais ils sont évidemment trop
livrés à eux-mêmes euh et quand ils
rencontrent la moindre difficulté le
moindre problème effectivement euh ils
ne savent pas vraiment vers qui se
tourner pour exprimer leur malaise leur
problème trouver des réponses à leur à
leur problèmes pour illustrer mes propos
par exemple à
l'UCI le représentant des coureurs est
nommé par le président de l'UCI il n'y a
pas d'élection il n'est pas élu par ses
pères il est nommé par les dirigeants de
l'UCI et le budget qui lui est alloué
vient de l'UCI comment voulez-vous qu'il
y ait une démocratie c'est pas possible
ça assure une grande indépendance oui
exactement madame donc pour finir euh je
voulais juste revenir sur deux points
sur la question de la la réalité du du
dialogue social c'est vrai que monsieur
Simon a comparé avec le système
nord-américain où là l'ensemble de la
réglementation est finalement basé sur
un système de
de de dialogue social et de collective
agreement N moins on peut aussi
remarquer que dans certains aut dans
certains autres pays notamment européens
on en est aussi beaucoup plus loin que
ce qui se passe en France il faut pas
voir complètement tout noir on est
plutôt au au milieu et il y a des des
certains certains États où c'est encore
plus compliqué qu'en France maintenant
je pense que effectivement le sport est
uniquement au début de du dialogue
social il y a encore beaucoup de de
progrès à faire et notamment en matière
de dopage c'est pas forcé forcément une
des questions qui qui est le le plus
efficace à ce niveau-là et simplement
pour revenir sur la question de du rôle
des des fédérations et et pour répondre
à Monsieur Labou je suis complètement
d'accord et je pense que enfin à l'heure
actuelle les le mouvement sportif seul
n'est pas capable de de gérer la la la
lutte contre le dopage moi je trouve un
peu dommage que aujourd'hui on n'est pas
également un représentant alors des
employeurs on l'a dit ou d'une
fédération ou d'une ligue parce que ce
serait quand même à eux de de
s'expliquer à à ce niveau-là vous savez
très bien que si on demande à la Ligue
professionnelle de football deevenenir
la ligue professionnelle de rugby nous
dira pourquoi pas nous bien sûr c'est
juste dans dans le débat bien sûr
essayer d'entrer dans le VI du sujet de
cette table ronde estimez-vous que la
lutte contre le dopage a fait
profondément le droit des sportifs
ou estimez-vous que ces atteintes
restent proportionnées au but recherché
de la lutte contre le dopage c'est
peut-être la question de départ très
générale qui s'adresse chacune et chacun
d'entre vous on va commencer par vous
puisque vous réclamiez la parole pour
autre chose mais vous allez je vais
faire le lien rassurez-vous non par
rapport à ce qui a été dit sur les
États-Unis il est clair aussi qu'aux
États-Unis là où les discipl ines se
sont organisé professionnellement assez
tôt la lutte contre l' dopage a pris du
retard c'est-à-dire que on sait très
bien que par exemple en baseball il y
avait des statistiques médicales qui
étaient pas vraiment réjouissantes parce
qu'on savait bien qu'il fallait assurer
du showaud donc c'est aussi le risque
donc le fait que les les sportifs
eux-mêmes s'organisent entre eux n'est
pas forcément en gage d'une efficacité
mais ça c'est le problème de
l'autorégulation en générale c'est pas
que le sport c'est l'autorégulation qui
ne marche pas pour répondre à votre
question je tiens sur les États-Unis a a
indiqué que quelques membres de la
commission sont allé passer 4 jours
intenses de travail aux États-Unis la
semaine dernière ù il y a 15 jours on
aura des choses à dire aussi en la
matière d'accord ou un petit complément
sur les résultats des contrôles aux
États-Unis notamment sur les sports
nonolympiques vous savez on retrouve
toujours la tranche des 1 à 2 % que l'on
retrouve ici dans les sports
olympiques continuez et et donc et là je
va Allis sur votre question euh sur la
question du du pouvoir des fédération et
des libertés je pense que là aussi mais
je vais insister c'est que on peut pas
demander les mêmes choses un sportif
amateur ou à une discipline où il y a
pas de professionnalisme où il y a peu
d'argent à des à des sportifs qui eux
sont professionnels avec de l'argent qui
leur permet de faire face à un certain
nombre d'obligations et c'est bien là le
problème c'est qu'effectivement
certaines obligations sont plus lourdes
pour d'autres que plus certaines que
pour d'autres après j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure la question de l'égalité des
sportifs bon moi l'égalité sportif elle
a jamais existé elle est c'est une
fiction juridique l'égalité des sportifs
ça c'est c'est intéressant c'est c'est
un concept mais ça reste à l'état du
concept est-ce que les sportifs sont des
souscitoyens évidemment que non
évidemment que non mais à partir du
moment on rentre dans un système à un
momenté il faut bien respecter les
règles un salarié qui est dans une
entreprise il va respecter le règlement
intérieur de l'entreprise donc on est
dans cette idée là simplement je pense
que il y a derrière et c'est bien là le
problème
le sport la volonté d'exemplarité c'est
qu'on va demander on va prêter au
sportifs toute une série de qualités
qu'on lui demande pas d'avoir et qui n'a
peut-être pas c'est d'illeur des
qualités moral et cetera et cetera et
donc partant de là il y a un effet de
représentation médiatique qui fait qu'on
va s'étonner qu'un sportif et plus pas
payer ses impôts et cetera et cetera
mais à la limite c'est un être humain
comme un autre simplement il doit être
bon dans sa
discipline partant de là c'est vrai que
tout est médiatisé mais je crois que à
un moment donné on rentre dans un
système et il est pas anormal il est pas
anormal de vouloir respecter les règles
du système après on peut discuter des
modalités et je su je suis très à l'aise
à la question de la localisation mais je
pense qu'il y a des modalités qui
peuvent être adaptées mais et ça il a
été parlé du du passeport biologique du
passeport
physiologique je vous livrer une
anecdote V qui est effectivement pas
médecin raconta que en début de saison
Christophe basson avit les résultat euh
quand les gens commençaient à se charger
il avit plus de résultat euh
effectivement physiologiquement il y en
a qui avaient des aptitudes l'autre il
les autres avaient d'autres aptitudes
euh plutôt les aptitudes physiologiques
donc je pense qu'effectivement le fait
de de de creuser dans la question du
passeport biologique et ou physiologique
peut être intéressant parce que si c'est
bien maîtrisé je pense que ça pourrait
d'autant lever un certainombre
d'hypothèque concernant les obligations
dans la
géolocalisation
merci monsieur Simon
monsieur le Président encore une très
bonne question que vous posez sur la
proportionnalité parce que c'est le cœur
c'est vraiment le cœur du sujet et de
notre réflexion et c'était le cœur de
mon propos liminire c'est que si on sort
un petit peu de la passion de l'émotion
de la défense de l'éthique de l'idéal et
cetera qui sont des concepts importants
mais qui sont
difficilement concrétisables en chiffre
pour étudier une proportionnalité une
efficacité il faut un constat de départ
il faut des chiffres il faudrait qu'on
puisse dire et je ne sais pas si c'est
possible voilà le dopage c'est ça je je
reviens toujours à cette approche
médicale par rapport aux consommations
que je connais bien on partle d'un état
des
lieux cet état des lieux il est le point
A en fonction des on fixe un objectif
qui est le point B voilà on veut faire
diminuer on veut que ça que ça
disparaisse et on met en place des
politiques et on évalue cette politique
en permanence quels sont l'efficacité
des moyens mises en cours euh c'est de
l'argent public c'est et cetera donc ce
sont des politiques euh de lutte contre
les consommations qui sont sans arrêt
évolués en fonction de constats qui qui
tendent d'être factuel enfin qui
j'espère le sont là et monsieur nigli
vient de le dire ah oui non mais les
statistiques les seules qu'on est ilells
sont pas
fiables donc comment dire si c'est
proportionnel comment comment
effectivement demain ne pas euh avoir
quelqu'un qui dit on a une idée on va
mettre une puce électronique euh pour
les sportifs comme ça ça sera réglé
est-ce que ça sera proportionnel je sais
pas si effectivement il y a un danger
immanent et une menace de mort
permanente sur les sportifs mettez-nous
des puces électroniques mais partons d'
d'un constat c'est tout ce que c'est
tout ce qu'il faudrait faire il y a pas
de constat c'est encore une fois on est
il y a une absence totale de de de de
concrétude alors pas de point de départ
pas d'objectif fixable des statistiques
qui sont que des contrôle positif mais
dont tout le monde sous-entend dit non
mais c'est bon faut pas se fill au
résultats des contrôles parce qu'on sait
c'est que alors finalement on sait quoi
comment définir de cette
proportionnalité comment comment pouvoir
mis à part effectivement et leve la main
essayer de poser des questions et de
suite on va vous mettre de côté en
disant oui mais bon s'ils font ça c'est
que ils se soumettent pas je je reprends
ce terme très très fort ils se
soumettent pas et s'ils se soumettent
pas c'est que finalement ils en sont eux
aussi voilà ça me rappelle la Grande
Inquisition à un moment donné et
j'aimerais et je pense que cette
commission d'IMP extrêmement importante
pour essayer de donner un axe factuel de
dépassionner et de et de partir de
choses concrètes pour arriver à des
choses concrètes encore une fois il
s'agit pas simplement de discours mais
de moyens très important de moyens
publics très importants quand je disais
tout à l'heure l'exemple du paludisme
soyons clair pourquoi le paludisme ne
déclenche pas un plan mondial on sait
très bien il y a des rapports nord-
sudud on sait très bien que le paludisme
c'est une maladie qui n'intéresse pas
forcément de manière prioritaire les
grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques par
parce que le continent touché en premier
ben n'a pas forcément et cetera et
cetera donc on sait très bien que les
acteurs d'un
problème définissent les politiques de
santé publique parce qu'il y a des
intérêts derrière et cetera et cetera là
il y a des organismes qui effectivement
collectent énormément de fonds doivent
justifier de leur action et cetera et
cetera soyons factuel et on pourra
répondre à votre question très
pertinente de la proportionnalité
merci c oui donc je j'adhère évidemment
complètement à ce que vient de dire
Serge juste moi je reviens sur le côté
par rapport à cette efficacité dans les
sports co par rapport à la
géolocalisation imposée à un ou deux
sportifs sur des effectifs de 30 joueurs
quand même la question se pose de savoir
pourquoi justement on en choisit qu'un
ou deux c'est déjà quand même une
question on a d'ailleurs posé cette
question aux divers présidents de de la
FLD qui se sont succédés la simple
réponse qu'on a eu c'était parce qu'on a
pas les moyens d'en cibler ou en tout
cas d'en localiser davantage donc j'ai
dit tout à l'heure dans mon introduction
qui avait déjà une injustice par rapport
à ce traitement hein sur le côté en plus
justement cible c'est le cas de le dire
hein sur sur les sur les un ou deux
joueurs sur lesquels repose cette cette
localisation et puis soyons là aussi un
peu pragmatique les deux joueurs le ou
les deux joueurs qui vont être ciblés
dans les effectifs s'ils sont pas trop
bêtes ces joueursl s'ils savent qu'en
effet ils sont encore plus susceptibles
d'être contrôlés que les autres joueurs
euh enfin voilà je vous laisse je je je
je je vois pas comment les comment
comment on arrivera justement si si si
l'objectif c'est d'éradiquer le dopage
dans le sport pro et dans les sports
collectifs notamment c'est vraiment pas
la bonne méthode parce que justement
c'est c'est c'est c'est anti c'est
antinomique en fait c'est c'est c'est
mal conçu dès le départ et qu'on nous
dise pas justement que c'est qu'une
question de moyen c'est pour ça qu'on en
revient nous à notre idée justement de
multiplier les contrôles inopinés sur
des tirages au sort sur des sur sur des
sur des effectifs encore une fois de 30
joueurs autant de fois que les moyens de
la FLD le permettent mais pas enfin de
sortir encore une fois de ce modèle des
sport individuels où là effectivement la
plupart des athlètes s'entraînent tout
seul on sait pas où ils sont ils sont
pas sous la responsabilité de
l'employeurs comme les SPORTCO 11 mois
sur 12 après il y a le problème des
vacances on y reviendra mais mais bon
j'étais aussi content d'entendre
monsieur N dire que il y a quelques
agences nationales qui font du zel mais
mais le Z que fait la FLD c'est pas un
bon zel parce que je viens de vous
expliquer qu'encore une fois la méthode
pour les SPORTCO n'est pas la bonne ils
n'auront jamais de meilleurs résultats
s'il continue comme ça
écoutez-nous merci Monsieur
nigli monsieur le Président
proportionnalité évidemment c'est un des
un des soucis dans l'établissement des
règles en matière
d'antidopage c'est une des difficultés
j'ai envie de dire de trouver la bonne
balance entre quelque chose d'efficace
qui permettent de lutter contre des
tricheurs qui parfois comme on vient de
le voir dans l'affaire hamstrong sont
très
sophistiqué et d'un autre côté de
respecter les droits des athlètes alors
en tout cas en ce qui concerne l'Agence
mondiale antidopage c'est une
préoccupation permanente qui s'est
traduit d'abord par la consultation les
consultations qui ont lieu dans
l'élaboration du code aussi par pour
rester juridique mais c'est quand même
finalement là-dessus que que ça se joue
la demande d'opinion à des ex per
indépendant sur des questions qui
pouvaient être des questions délicates
et c'est la même chose qui se produira
dans le cas de la révision actuelle où
l'ancien président de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme va rendre un avis
droit sur un certain nombre de points
qui font partie du nouveau du nouveau
code pour s'assurer qu'effectivement ces
respects là sont pris en compte
maintenant après on peut sortir du débat
technique et juridique pour rentrer dans
l'émotionnel on peut parler d'avoir un
état des lieux absolu quand on commence
avant de faire quoi que ce soit c'est
parfait faisons un sondage de tous les
sportifs demandons leurs S sont dopés
vous aurez un un résultat intéressant je
veux dire il faut se rendre compte aussi
de la réalité du terrain que quand on a
une affaire Armstrong où on voit ce qui
ressort si quand on voit ce qui ressort
du système qui est là derrière alors les
sports collectifs diront ça n'est pas le
cas dans les sports collectifs c'est
différent mais c'est quand même la
réalité c'est que les informations qui
remontent au niveau des organisations
antiopage sont quand même des éléments
importants en dehors des chiffres sur la
façon dont ça se passe dans certains
milieux et dans certains sports et
donnez-les-nous ces informations ces
allez lire allez lire les des
dépositions des cyclistes dans l'affire
Amstrong non mais vous parlez des oui
très bien ok allez les lire vous vous
comprendrez que le système vous parlez
d'information qui remonte des Agen de
lutteage un peu partout et cetera encore
une fois oui parlons de choses concrètes
parlons de choses qui existent d'ord et
mettons des systèmes en place par
rapport à ces problèmes mais vous vous
vous universalisez immédiatement
immédiatement tout et tout le monde
non mais je pense que je sais pas
comment vous faites intellectuellement
je ne sais pas donc voilà donc je veux
dire les les chiffres étant ce qu'ils
sont je pense qu'il faut pas non plus se
focaliser unement et pour répondre à
votre demande les statistiques des
années à venir seront meilleurs puisque
les systèmes Lama n'ayant pas de
statistique fiable remontant de la part
des organisations nationales a mis en
place maintenant un système où elle
demande au laboratoir de fournir des
informations supplémentaires puisque les
laboratoires sont finalement le nœud par
lequel au moins tous les contrôles
passent pour essayer d'avoir des
statistiques à l'échelle mondiale qui
aont etelles pourront être interprété il
y aura peut-être d'autres études aussi
qui sont en cours donc voilà mais je
veux dire il faut pas non plus être naïf
et penser que en attendant d'avoir un
état des lieux il faut rien faire
monsieur bet oui je vais me permettre de
de rebondir sur ce qui a été dit donc on
parle de géo loocalisation les les les
contraintes la la soumission et je je je
vous rejoins monsieur monsieur Simon
bien entendu mais les cyclistes étaient
depuis 1998 laaffaire ftina tout le
monde a pu constater dans un tel état
qu'il fallait bien un moment donné faire
tout ce enfin beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui qui flirtaient avec la limite
de la légalité je suis d'accord avec le
respect des droits des sportifs on a
toujours fliré effectivement avec avec
ça et aujourd'hui effectivement for de
constater que on est toujours dans cette
peut-être parfois illégal mais c'est pas
la la la la quantité des contrôles on
s'aperçoit que c'est totalement
inefficace la Armstrong à chaque fois
avant ses révélations il il il pour se
défendre il disait mais attendez je suis
contrôler je sais pas 20 25 fois par
mois et je suis négatif donc je suis pas
dopé on aurait pu le contrôler 10 fois
plus encore il aurait toujours été
négatif donc c'est la qualité des
contrôles et les moments pertinents où
il faut les réaliser là la la géol
loocalisation est assez efficace dans
par rapport à ça pas suffisamment mais
là où je veux en venir c'est que il faut
donner les moyens aux scientifiques
aujourd'hui qui travaillent dans des
laboratoires qui mettent au point des
molécules des médicaments qui sont là
d'abord pour soigner les gens
malades bien évidemment mais il faut
quand même trouver le le moyen que des
scientifiques puissent travailler
aujourd'hui sur les molécules qui sont
réalisées par les scientifiques pour
soigner les malades mais qui sont très
vite utilisés par par les sportifs et
pour lesquels on ne peut pas
retrouver les effets dans les analyses
de sang dans les analyses d'urine et
cetera parce que je puis vous assurer
que le sportif qui veut tricher bien
entendu celui qui vraiment a une vision
de la pratique de son sport avec un
accompagnement dopant il est informé
très rapidement de tout ce qui est
nouveau et capable de l'utiliser tout
aussi rapidement donc il faut permettre
vraiment aux scientifiques et leur
donner les moyens de travailler sur les
molécules qui sont utilisées aujourd'hui
et surtout celles qui seront utilisées
demain pour se doper merci ser Simon a
demandé la parole ah ben je comm vous
voulez vous lever la main moi je donne
la parole he il excusez-moi madame
allez-y alors je fais vite merci
euh juste sur d'un d'un point de vue
juridique je pense que pour pour
répondre à votre question
euh il est pas possible de nier que le
dispositif actuel de lutte contre le
dopage porte certaines atteintes aux
libertés individuelles des sportif je
pense pas que ce soit possible après euh
d'un point de vue juridique moi je pense
qu'il est possible euh d'apporter des
des justifications et euh de considérer
que que ce ce dispositif euh est
proportionné au regard de la nécessité
de la lutte contre le dopage par contre
je pense aussi que de de nombreux
progrès sont encore à faire dans ce
domaine-là
euh du point de vue de de l'Agence
mondiale antidopage du point de vue des
des institutions sportive et que ça
viendra par un un dialogue avec avec les
les sportifs mais vraiment enfin de mon
point de vue et et juridiquement je
pense que ces atteintes euh peuvent être
considérées comme comme
justifiées
merci merci Monsieur à vous je
recommence pas le tour si vous le voulez
bien on essaie de allez-y ben justement
ça me permet de de de de de poursuivre
de rebondir sur ce propos
euh je suis ravi euh d'avoir entendu
monsieur nigli dire il l'a dit il n'y a
pas d'état des lieux cétait le but moi
mon but ici c'est de poser cela il n'y a
pas d'état des lieux donc tout ce
dispositif toutes ces énergies tous ces
moyens partent aujourd'hui d'une absence
d'état des lieux c'est
dit ce qui me fait rebondir sur vos
propos comment justifier de la
proportionnalité quelque chose si on
sait pas ce qu'il y a en
face c'est une quadrature du cercle je
je je n'ai pas la réponse mais c'est
pour ça que cette cette question est
extrêmement importante de la
proportionnalité parce que encore une
fois ça nous fait remonter à la source
et dire mais voyons ce dont nous parlons
or nous ne voyons pas ce dont nous
parlons deuxième chose Monsieur Lapouble
parlait on rentre dans une entreprise il
a un règlement intérieur évidemment le
règlement intérieur il est soumis à la
loi si un entrepreneur qui met un
règlement intérieur qui atteint
certaines libertés qui atteint certains
droits il y a quelqu'un qui va lever la
main ce règlement intérieur il est pas
valable il y a pas une
extraterritorialité dans une entreprise
juridiquement et dans le sport à mon
avis il doit en être re exactement
pareil dernier point on parle évidemment
et c'est important maintenant d'aborder
de l'efficacité de la lut antidopage
alors je disais les statistiques
effectivement sont surprenantes et on a
tous cette impression que c'est c'est
inefficace et bien sûr le cas Armstrong
est mis en avant oui pourquoi reprenons
un petit abord médical quand la médecine
met en place un test de dépistage d'une
maladie ou de quelque chose il y a deux
critères pour faire simple de critères
d'efficacité d'un test la sensibilité la
spécificité la sensibilité c'est de sa
capacité à détecter la la maladie donc
de réagir positivement de pas faire trop
de faux négatif quoi et puis la
spécificité c'est de faire de réagir
pour ce que l'on cherche de pas faire
trop de faux positif comme on dit le
contrôle urinaire Armstrong le démontre
il absolument pas efficace 500 et
quelques contrôles jamais positif donc
il n'est pas sensible la méthode de la
lutte antidopage aujourd'hui le socle de
la lutte antidopage aujourd aujourd'hui
c'est le contrôle urinaire et ce n'est
pas sensible et ce n'est pas spécifique
parce que non seulement ça fait des
quantités de faux négatifs et ça tout le
monde l'a présent à l'esprit c'est le
fameux letmotif la lutte antidopage
n'est pas efficace mais en plus il fait
un paquet de faux positif c'est-à-dire
ce que donnait souligné Sylvain tout à
l'heure un contrôle normal ne veut pas
dire sportif d'OP absolument pas ça veut
dire cannabis ça veut dire aut ça veut
dire euh
substance présente dans les à un moment
donné mais pas forcément augmentation
des performances donc pas de spécificité
pas de
sensibilité compliqué la lutte
antiopage monsieur Simon c'est très
intéressant tout ce que vous nous dites
mais soyez plus concret que faut-il
faire vous demander de de réformer la
lutte antiopage si on pouvait simplement
si on pouvait simplement alors je n'ai
pas cette ambition monsieur le président
vraiment je n'ai pas cette ambition
aujourd'hui on est on en est un tel
point que si j'avais un objectif encore
une fois c'est semer cette idée de
gagner en raison et en lucidité de
comprendre qu'il y a une espèce encore
une fois de course d'escalade qui ne
part pas de choses concrètes qui part
sur sur un besoin sur des choses encore
une fois symbolique importante pour une
société mais qui franchissent les lignes
une à une parce qu'encore une fois
l'efficacité n'étant pas démontrée le
fléo est toujours présent parce qu'on
narrive pas à le dénicher ce fameux fléo
donc il faut aller toujours toujours
plus loin il y a une impériosité d'agir
qui n'est pas là pour être plus efficace
mais pour démontrer la détermination si
je pouvais juste introduire un petit peu
cette notion de dire allez prenons un
petit peu de recul arrêtons d'escalader
arrêtons de franchir des lignes les unes
les unes en les justifiant et en faisant
des sportifs des
souscitoyens peut-être que j'aurais
réussi après réformer la lutte antiopage
laissez-moi un peu de temps je reviens
ou le temps presse à vous écouter au
départ de votre intervention donc ça
presse mais il y a pas de solution
enfin Simon du coup le droit du travail
ça fait toujours plaisir de de de
ok simplement sur cet aspect notre table
ronde sur localisation contrôle groupe
cible et cetera je crois qu'on a on a un
petit peu progressé mais simplement sur
sur sur un point d'ailleurs monsieur
Boyet j'avais noté que l'Union nationale
les coureurs cyclistes professionnels se
disait favorable à la localisation des
coureurs dès
2002 et au contrôle inopiné dès 2006 bon
et puis globalement je crois sous les
contrôles
inopiné il me semble que le sentiment
général c'est que dans ce rapport entre
contrôle prévisible et contrôle
imprévisible l'accent doit être
davantage mis maintenant sur les
contrôles inopiner on sait très bien
qu'il y a tout un ensemble de
contraintes qui vont nous amener à
procéder à des choix des arbitrages
notamment des contraintes physiques
financières et pas simplement simplement
sur un point précis et justement
monsieur Lapouble j'en suis sûr va
pouvoir apporter un élément de réponse
quels sont les les les garanties de
confidentialité pour assurer la
protection des données collecté par le
logiciel Adams est-ce qu'elle vous
semble suffisante c'est un point je sais
très précis mais qui est quand même
essentiel qui rejoint toute la question
de de la liberté
individuelle je sais pas si la question
est posée par uneadvertance ou sa pas ce
que j'avais signne un article dessus
euh effectivement moi j'avis quelques
doutes sur le système Adams mais c'est
pas le système Adams en soi c'est tout
système informatique et tout transfert
de données puisque effectivement les
données partent de France si on est sur
un sportif français elle part de la FLD
c'est transmis à Montréal à l'Agence
mondiale antidopage à Montréal qui est
compétent puisque Lama est une
institution à non lucratif donc c'est la
Commission des donné à la formation du
Québec euh je parle sous le contrôle
igli jusque-l on est encore sous une
certaine forme de contrôle et après ce
qui va se passer c'est que si le sportif
navigue voyage ces données vont partir
dans un pays on sait pas lequel et là
c'est la grande inconnue
puisqueeffectivement les degrés de
protection sont plus ou moins importants
et cetera donc ça c'était effectivement
une inconnue et j'étais un pe inqué
puisque il peut y avoir des divulgations
certains aspects de la vie privée et
cetera euh que ce soit parce qu'il y a
violation du système de sécurité
informatique ou que ce soit et ça c'est
plutôt le facteur humeur c'est que
effectivement on n'est pas à l'abri
parce que je l'ai constaté
personnellement sur une mission
d'observation on n'est pas à l'abri de
voir des médecins contrôleurs qui parce
qu'ils ont une star et cetera ben vont
le soir entre deux bières passez-moi
expression livrer des informations qui
peuvent être des informations sur le
dopage ou sur la vie privée qui
correspond pas à celle qui est affichée
et cetera donc ça c'est un point sur
lequel effectivement je me suis inquiété
puisque je pense qu'il faut être très
vigilant par rapport à ça euh la qualité
euh de de la protection des données et
après le fait que certaines données sont
transférées dans des pays ou peuvent
être transféréses dans les pays où il y
a aucune sécurité euh aucune sécurité
technique et aucune sécurité juridique
ce qui pose évidemment euh un un un un
vrai problème donc là-dessus
effectivement je pense qu' on a une
interrogation mais là je voulais juste
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit puisque
euh sur la question du du constat euh on
n'est pas en Scien expérimental
c'est-à-dire que on est sur un phénomène
sociologique et j'ai entendu il y a 25
ans les mêmes propos que cher Simon mais
non c'est pas ça existe pas et cetera et
cetera on me disait on n pas d'établ
j'ai entendu ça on n pas de de constat
exact et cetera et cetera je vais juste
rappeler une chose concernant l'affaire
hamsong l'affaire hamsong c'est pas que
des contrôles négatifs c'est aussi un
système de corruption mise en place pour
éviter que les contrôles aient lieu au
bon moment c'est aussi des contrôles qui
ont été subtilisés donc c'est tout ça la
faireson donc si on parle de fait il
faut que les faits soient concret c'est
un véritable système mafieux qui a été
mis en place pour faire en sorte que
évidemment la plupart du temps il était
contrôlé négatif mais les for où il
était contô les positifs on faisait en
sorte que c'est juste ça
laaffon merci monsieur nigli que
pensez-vous de tout
ça merci monsieur le
Président d'abord pour répondre très
briment à à monsieur Simon quand même
parce que on peut dire des choses qui
sont bien pour le débat et et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur Lapouble mais il y a
des choses qu'on peut pas dire parce
qu'elles sont fausses quand on dit que
le système génère des faux positifs
c'est faux il ça c'est arrivé il y en a
eu quelques-uns ce sont des accidents et
c'est c'est vrai mais le système ne gère
pas dé faux positifs parce que euh tout
ce qui est rendu par un laboratoire ne
se transforme pas en une infraction
antiopage ce qui est rendu par un
laboratoire ne se transforme pas en une
infraction antidopage parce que soit il
y a une autorisation d'usage à des fins
thérapeutiques soit il y a d'autres
explications qui son trîn mais c'est pas
le laboratoire qui a rendu inf faux
positif et qui a mal fait son travail
c'est que dans la chaîne de de gestion
des résultats il y a des raisons qui
expliquent ce résultat donc attention
quand même à ce qu'on dit c'est pas la
même chose qu'un fa positif euh
maintenant sur le le logiciel Adam c'est
la confidentialité eu d'abord il y a eu
beaucoup de discussions là-dessus
notamment avec l'Union européenne ce
qu'a dit Monsieur lapoubl juste les
informations du système Adams
effectivement vont sur des serveurs qui
sont situés à Montréal Montréal et
l'agence mon est sous lislation de la
Commission de la protection des données
québécoises pour des raisons techniques
de droit Canadiens euh la loi québécoise
grosso modo est un copier-collé de la
loi française mais enfin ça c'est un une
anecdote euh mais c'est la réalité euh
et on attend aujourd'hui que la
Commission européenne rende une décision
je dirais administrative où elle
reconnaisse que la loi québécoise assure
une protection adéquate voilà ça c'est
pour le côté technique maintenant là où
euh c'est pas tout à fait exact dans le
les commentaires du professeur lapoupe
c'est que les données une fois qu'elles
sont dans le système Adams ne sont vues
et visibles que par les organisations
qui ont le droit de voir ces
informations c'est-à-dire par le sportif
par sa fédération internationale et par
l'agence nationale antidopage qui est
responsable de lui personne d'autre si
une autre organisation doit y avoir
accès par exemple parce que le sportif
va s'entraîner dans un pays X ou Y et
que l'agence qui est en charge de cet
athlète admettons la France et l'athlète
va s'entraîner au Mexique si l'agence
française veut déléguer à l'agence
mexicaine le droit d'aller faire un
certain nombre de contrôle sur ce
sportif pendant qu'il s'entraîne elle
peut choisir de le faire c'est un acte
volontaire qu'elle n'accomplira que
lorsqu'elle aura les garanties de la
part de la contrepartie en l'occurrence
dans mon exemple mexicaine que les
garanties de protection seront là et
cetera elle peut le faire en obtenant
ses garanties de façon contractuelle
notamment donc il y a pas parce que le
système est global un partage immédiat
avec tout le monde de toutes les
formation c'est un système qui est
extrêmement cloisonné justement pour
éviter ça et c'est ce qu'on a discuté de
nombrees reprises alors de notre point
de vue du point de vue Lama clairement
aujourd'hui et on le dit on le répète le
système Adams est celui qui offre le
plus de protection aux sportifs parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on voit dans les cas où
le système Adams n'est pas utilisé les
informations circulent quand même parce
que la réalité du sport c'est que les
les sportif bouge vont dans un autre
pays dans un autre qu'ils ont besoin ces
informations besoin de circuler que ce
soit d'ailleurs dans leur pure intérêt
par exemple la demande d'une
autorisation d'usage à Desf
thérapeutique et lorsque le système
adam'est pas utilisé ces informations là
circulent par des voies non sécurisé par
email par fax et cetera sans que
personne n de contrôle donc finalement
le constat aujourd'hui c'est que le
système Alam c'est un système
informatique tout système informatique
présente ses propres risques l'agence
investit et met tout en œuvre pour
assurer une sécurité qui soit le maximum
mais lorsqu'il n'est pas utilisé ces
garanties là ne sont pas prê présente et
le risque est plus important merci
monsieur le Président
merci monsur le rapporteur oui on va
passer à un autre aspect de de ce sujet
si vous en êtes d'accord c'est la
question de la de la pénalisation de
l'usage de ces produits parce que là
aussi tout au long de nos auditions nous
avons entendu des des propositions des
positions tout à fait disparates tout à
fait différentes certains ont parlit
même de de double peine qu'il fallait
éviter que la sanction sportive était
largement suffisante euh certains nous
ont dit que il était impératif de passer
par une sanction pénale ça va faciliter
les les enquêtes les contrôles les le
travail des des services de de police de
gendarmerie les douanes lolest et cetera
quel est quel est votre votre sentiment
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
pénalisation de l'usage peut être un
élément favorable facilitant euh à la
lutte
antidopage bon pas tous en même
temps question je merci l'été on a aussi
entendu que par exemple pour les sports
collectifs il fallait aller vers des
sanctions
collectives c'est un peu une incitation
à la réaction monsieur Simon réagit tout
de
suite on remet la punition collective
vous avez disparu depuis un moment non
non mais allez-y je prends mon élan
alors as si vous
souhaitez alors sur sur la question de
la la pénalisation donc qui est bien de
de l'usage de produits d'pan euh j'avoue
que de mon point de vue euh autant il
est absolument nécessaire de conserver
un caractère pénal pour un certain
nombre d'infractions justement parce
qu'elle concerne des personnes qui ne
sont pas des des sportifs et c'est
absolument indispensable de pouvoir
sanctionner euh ces personnes-là parce
que finalement encore une fois c'est un
système global et quand il y a un
sportif dopé et ben il y a aussi tout un
entourage derrière qui gère ce dopage et
il est absolument indispensable de
pouvoir sanctionner ces personneslà
autant s'agissant du sportif lui-même
euh de mon point de vue la sanction
sportive reste la sanction
prioritaire et je serais pas forcément
en faveur d'une pénal ationtion de de
l'usage de dopage pour passer sur la la
seconde question et la question des des
sanctions euh collectives je sais pas si
euh c'est c'est exactement à ça dont
vous pensez mais sur les questions de de
de localisation en tout cas et si on
passe sur un un débat dont on a déjà un
peu parlé au niveau des sports
collectifs en revanche il y a peut-être
une réflexion à avoir sur
l'implication des des clubs et aussi la
possibilité de de sanctionner les les
clubs à ce à cet égard puisque à l'heure
actuelle même si les clubs peuvent avoir
la responsabilité de de renseigner les
informations c'est finalement toujours
sur le sportif que pèsera une une
éventuelle sanction et que ça il y a
peut-être d'autres d'autres systèmes qui
peuvent être envisagés à à ce niveau-là
euh et notamment je je vois ce qui ce
qui se passe au niveau au niveau de
l'UFA où il y a un un système qui est
progressif avec certaines sanctions qui
peuvent être prononcés contre contre les
clubs eux-mêmes et pas directement
contre les sportifs
oui bien bien entendu je crois
qu'effectivement la sanction sportive
pour le sportif elle se suffit elle-même
je je le pense il faut évidemment que ce
soit proportionné par rapport à la faute
hein il y a des accidents en terme de de
dopage il y a des des coureurs bon je
parle beaucoup de cyclistes que
finalement c'est ce que je connais le
mieux mais il y a des athlètes qui
peuvent se retrouver positifs en ayant
utilisé des des
médicaments mais pas dans un but pour
d'amélioration de ses performances donc
effectivement il faut être très prudent
mais l'athlète le cour cycliste
finalement c'est le dernier maillon
d'une chaîne par quand il est positif un
vrai dopage là dans ces cas-là avérer
démontrer et
cetera il ne peut
pas être positif sans sans la complicité
d'utilisation de produits dopan de
médecins
de de laisser faire de la part de de de
de leur
dirigeants beaucoup d'exemples
sont sont sont précis dans le milieu du
cyclisme on voit bien qu'il y a des
médecins en Italie aujourd'hui qui sont
à peine poursuivis bon en Espagne
l'affaire Puerto démontre que le docteur
Fuentes avait des responsabilités mais
les lois en Espagne de l'époque
n'étaient est pas proportionné par
rapport à la faute aujourd'hui
constatée sur le docteur fentes donc
voilà ce que je veux dire c'est que pour
le sportif sanction sportive mais pour
tous ceux qui ont favorisé et qui ont
accompagné et qui ont fourni les cours
cyclistes en produit de Pan là je suis
désolé mais il faut des sanctions
pénales voilà ce que je ce que je pense
par rapport à ça merci de de votre
réponse ces sanctions pénales existent
pour trafic et
cetera la question et vous y avez
répondu c'était les les sportifs
eux-mêmes les
dopé monsieur
nigli monsieur le Président alors je
pense que je rejoins la position de de
de Monsieur Boyer dans le sens où il est
indispensable que tout ce qui est
entourage de l'athlète puisse être
poursuivi
pénalement la difficulté quand on on
parle de l'athlète lui-même c'est
évidemment qu'il est nécessaire de
pouvoir envisager des enquêtes et de
donner les moyens de pouvoir
finalement conduire des investigations
aussi autour des sportifs est-ce que
pour faire ça il est nécessaire de
pénaliser l'infraction ou est-ce qu'il y
a des moyens de pouvoir
donner ce cadre juridique nécessaire aux
enquêtes sans que l'infraction tant que
telle soit pénal je pense que les
systèmes vont varier d'une juridiction à
l'autre et que et que il y aura une
certaine diversité aujourd'hui on
constate quand même par exemple que
l'Italie qui a une loi
pénale n'a ma connaissance jamais envoyé
un athlète en prison mais à diligenté
des enquêtes qui ont pu être menées
grâce au cadre juridique qui était en
place donc la réflexion elle est là le
but c'est pas d'envoyer les athlètes
consommateurs en prison mais c'est que
le cadre juridique qui entoure cette
problématique soit
suffisamment permettre disons à à la
police et et au douanes éventuellement
de faire de faire leur travail et et
cette difficulté là je pense qu'elle est
pas forcément elle elle va pas se
résoudre de façon identique dans tous
les
pays
merci madame messieurs on arrive parce
que le temps passe
vite je vous en prie juste ça va être
très court sur cette question là malgré
tout puisque bon je su quand même
représentant des des des sportifs je
l'ai vécu euh directement pendant de
nombreuses années euh je crois qu'il
faut bien évaluer le poids de la
sanction sportive quand même parce que
quand on prive un athlète ou un sportif
professionnel là on revient sur la sur
la dualité entre le sportif amateur et
le sportif professionnel mais le sportif
professionnel vous le privez de de
années puisque c'est le hein les deux
années de suspension qui sont
pratiquement le tarif ou en tout cas qui
peuvent aller qui peuvent être le tarif
pour un pour un cas de de dopage avéré
réel de années de privation quand même
de sa profession je pense que avant
d'envisager des une dimension pénale je
pense que la sanction sportive est déjà
très très forte et très très lourde elle
est très dissuasive donc je pense que
voilà je j'ai cette position là et puis
sur la sanction collective il faut
surtout pas aller vers ça faut surtout
pas aller vers ça sauf à considérer
encore une fois j'y reviendrai dans ma
conclusion qu'on va faire une lutte
antidopage qui concernera tous les
sportifs tous les les les joueurs d'un
même effectif de la même manière ce qui
est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui
merci sans surprise je suis contre la
pénalisation des sanctions pour les pour
les sportifs d'pé
euh tant
que et surtout tant que la lutte
antidopage encore une fois sera n'aura
pas des soccles solide en matière de et
de constat et de de et de méthode et il
me semble effectivement que on doit
rester au sein de de la réglementation
de la réglementation
sportive mer
merci si chacun s'est allez-y monsieur
la juste ben je vais je crois que tout
le monde est à peu près d'accord sur
merci sur le fait de ne pas pénaliser je
l'avais écrit sur la loi de 89 qui est
dépénalisé simplement j'attire
l'attention sur le fait qu'il y a déjà
une disposition qui pénalise le sportif
dans le droit français c'est que la
détention de produit est pénalisé ce qui
est un moyen indirect pour un sportif de
pouvoir être condamné parce qu'il a des
médicaments donc je pense qu'il faudrait
se poser la question de savoir que fait
cette disposition là on sait bien que
cette disposition ça permet d'ouvrir des
enquêtes euh concernant la pénalisation
évidemment les tribunaux sont
suffisamment combrés donc de grâce
n'allons pas là sur les peines
collectives ça me semble là aussi
totalement abérant mais j'aimerais juste
insister sur et revenir sur un point de
l'ASP de l'affaire hamsong l'affaire
hamsong elle est sortie pas parce que le
procureur américain a pu mener son
enquête il a il a fait choublanc c'est
parce que précisément c'est une
commission administrative américaine qui
a pu ouvrir l'enquête ce qui montre bien
que si on s'en donne les moyens il y a
pas besoin de pénaliser toute le de
pénaliser le dopage parce que
précisément on peut par d'autres voies
et je finirai sur des propos de Madame
NMAS Marti qui est professeur au Collège
de France qui avait dit dans un qui
avait écrit que effectivement souvent la
sanction disciplinaire ou administrative
est parfois plus sévère que la sanction
pénale merci je vous propose donc
d'engager ce
qui sera votre conclusion en vous
demandant peut-être de de dire deux mots
sur le passeport biologique dans le
cadre de votre conclusion puisque
c'était un des sujets qu'on aurait voulu
évoquer mais l'heure avance et euh on va
commencer en étant enfin pour une fois
galant et en proposant à Madame prés
recipon de commencer les le volet
conclusion si vous voulez bien merci
monsieur le Président
euh
pour conclure je pense qu'effectivement
on a on a touché à pas mal de de
sujets il y a deux trois choses sur
lequel j'aurais voulu revenir en terme
de conclusion la la première était la
question de la définition du dopage et
là c'est peut-être sûrement parce que je
suis juriste mais j'avoue avoir du mal
avec certaines personnes qui à chaque
fois disent il y a une infraction
antidopage mais finalement c'est pas du
dopage euh là on a enfin pour moi dans
la mesure où il y a une infraction du
dopage on on est dans le dopage et là on
se pose la question de la définition
finalement du dopage on peut avoir une
définition morale éthique et cetera et
puis une définition juridique ou
finalement la définition du dopage c'est
faire quelque chose qui est interdit par
la réglementation antidopage et en
l'occurrence trois nocho c'est interdit
par la réglementation antiopage c'est
une infraction à la lutte contre le
dopage et euh c'est c'est pas le lieu
ici mais du coup on découle une
réflexion qui pourrait avoir lieu sur
justement comment et défin enfin sont
définis les infractions à la lutte
contre le dopage je crois que ça fait
partie des réflexions que mène
actuellement l'Agence mondiale
antidopage dans la révision du code et à
ce à ce titre là je je trouve je trouve
intéressant de de le mentionner euh sur
la question des du dopage et des
libertés publiques qui nous intéressait
précisément aujourd'hui euh
je je conclurai juste en en rappelant ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure que certes
il y a des atteintes au aux libertés
individuelles que donc la question à se
poser est de savoir dans quelle mesure
la la lutte contre le dopage
euh nécessite ces atteintes la question
de de la
proportionnalité selon moi encore une
fois des justifications sont possibles
euh il ne faut surtout pas oublier le le
contexte international et justement
prendre en compte l'ensemble l'ensemble
de la réglementation au niveau
international euh comme le disait
monsieur la pouble il ne faut pas euh se
focaliser sur certaines disciplines très
médiatiques mais envisager l'ensemble de
la lutte contre le dopage d'un point de
vue euh global et euh sur de fait c'est
peut-être l'ensemble de de la réflexion
autour de la la lutte contre le dopage
effectivement qu'il faudra euh à
l'avenir réfléchir refonder euh
peut-être également en menant en menant
des études euh et sans sans prendre ça
comme comme point de départ pour dire la
lutte contre le dopage actuellement
euh doit être complètement révisé c'est
vrai qu'il serait très très utile
d'avoir des des chiffres
notamment sur la les conséquen
finalement euh que que peut avoir le
dopage et ça c'est des des données qui
qui manquent et euh bah lancer des
cohortes sur sur les conséquences du
dopage mais aussi finalement les
conséquences du sport de ha niveau tout
court sur la santé des athlètes mais à
long terme c'est quelque chose qui est
assez massif et qui prendra du temps
mais euh mais je considère effectivement
que c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
être euh tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant sur le passeport biologique
dont on a dont on n pas parlé
euh c'est assez difficile finalement en
France d'avoir un positionnement dans la
mesure où bah il a pas encore été mise
en place euh comme on le disait tout à
l'heure donc il y a une ça a été
introduit dans la loi mais ça ne sera ça
ne rentrera en vigueur que que dans le
futur pour l'instant il y a une une
réflexion qui est menée autour de ça
donc c'est un peu compliqué ça semble
euh ça semble effectivement être une des
mesures qui se montreraiit le plus
efficace euh effectivement les contrôles
euh qui plus est euh euh qui dont le le
sportif est est averti à l'avance en
compétition semble avoir montré une
certaine forme d'inefficacité euh et
donc du coup le système de localisation
le passeport biologique peut être une
solution maintenant à ce jour enfin en
tout cas personnellement j'ai pas assez
d'éléments pour pour me prononcer plus
particulièrement là-dessus merci
beaucoup monsieur Boyer
merci écoutez je commencerai par vous
dire que
lorsque j'ai eu 20 ans j'ai voulu
épouser une carrière de cour
cycliste j'imaginais pas à quel
point le dopage était présent dans dans
ce sport je veux dire aussi que
pratiquement tous mes copains tous mes
camarades en France à l'étranger tous
ceux qui ont débuté avec moi ont
constaté et rencontrer le le dopage au
fur à mesure de l'évolution de leur
carrière je veux dire par là que on a
rencontré très très très très peu
d'athlètes qui décidaient de pratiquer
leur sport avec un protocole
dopant on a tous une rencontre avec le
dopage on le reçoit un petit peu aussi
en en héritage de nos pères et il m'est
arrivé de rêver de d'avoir pu démarrer
ma carrière euh sans cet héritage et
aujourd'hui je je pense qu'il faut créer
les la la possibilité à des jeunes
athlètes qui vont démarrer leur carrière
de ne pas avoir cette rencontre avec le
dopage et si j'ai eu cette rencontre
avec le dopage c'est bien qu'à un moment
donné mes résultats n'étaient pas à la
hauteur de mes
espérances que j'avais commencé à fonder
une famille m'installer dans la vie et
qu'il a bien fallu que je
survive d'où ma rencontre avec le dopage
et mes pratiques dopandes qui ont été
légères par rapport à ce qu'on connaît
mais qui ont été
réel en tout cas j'étais seul et livré
avec moi-même je n'avais personne à qui
parler personne a a rencontré pour
expliquer mon
problème face à l'utilisation ou pas de
de produits
d'opan et j'ai fini par me débrouiller
par moi-même et prolonger un petit peu
plus ma carrière donc voilà je
souhaiterais qu'aujourd'hui des gamins
qui démarrent leur carrière ne
rencontrent pas le dopage comme j'ai pu
le rencontrer en tout cas s'il le
rencontre qu'il
puisse avoir une oreille attentive et
que des gens puissent leur proposer et
leur apporter des solutions pour ne pas
aller vers le vers le dopage par rapport
à au sujet qui nous qui nous anime
aujourd'hui oui la la gé géolocalisation
elle est euh
elle est pas encore elle est pas elle
est contraignante je suis tout à fait
d'accord euh mais elle est quand même
assez efficace elle est quand même assez
efficace je peux vous assurer que de
nombreux coureurs cyclistes qui
imaginaent euh partir à droite à gauche
s'isoler à droite à gauche pour préparer
commencer un protocole de Pan euh ont
mis un frein à ces pratiques grâce à la
géolocalisation quant au passeport
biologique bon je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure je pense que il est intéressant
mais je pense qu'il faut aller vers un
passeport physiologique qui sera
beaucoup plus intéressant et d'ailleurs
qui permettra d'accompagner un athlète
lorsqu'il sera en
difficulté pour l'aider à passer ce cap
et non pas à prendre des décisions qu'il
pourrait regretter par la suite merci
merci à vous Monsieur nigli Merci
monsieur le Président
euh écoutez après ce que vient de dire
monsieur Boyer je crois que je peux pas
décrire mieux la raison d'êide de la
lutte contre le dopage et le fait que ce
qu' vient de dire notamment pour les
jeunes notamment pour l'avenir du sport
est le moteur principal de la lutte
contre le dopage et que même si
aujourd'hui on n pas tous les chiffres
qu'on aimerait peut-être avoir c'est ce
discours là qu'on entend de la part de
beaucoup beaucoup d'athlètes d'athlètes
propres d'athlètes qui espèrent qui vont
pouvoir pratiquer leur sport dans les
conditions descente donc je pense qu'il
y a pas de meilleure réponse aujourd'hui
à à aux propos qui disent on veut des
statistiques
maintenant la lutte contre le dopage est
en mutation
elle est en mutation parce qu'on se rend
compte que évidemment les contrôles ne
sont pas le seul angle d'attaque il y a
les investigations il y a d'autres
moyens il y a la coopération avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique il faut
travailler dans bon nombre de domaines
pour que le le système soit cohérent et
le système soit efficace il y a pas de
doute là-dessus il faut donc que les
moyens d'une lutte efficace soi là tant
au niveau national qu'au niveau
international et je pense que c'est un
effort de tous les instants et une
priorité qui doit rester une priorité
notamment pour les gouvernements pour la
localisation c'est indispensable de
continuer à localiser les athlètes en
tout cas ceux qui sont dans une certaine
catégorie d'athlètees maintenant bien
entendu si on peut faciliter la vie de
ces athlètes c'est ce qu'il faut faire
et c'est ce qu'on essayer de faire
notamment par le B de la
technologie avec les applications
mobiles et cetera aujourd'hui un athlète
peut être donner sa localisation elle a
changé jusque peu de temps avant le
contrôle depuis sa tablette mobile des
choses comme ça donc on va faciliter
leur leur quotidien parce que tout le
monde est d'accord que c'est quelque
chose de contraignant mais le système
reste quand même quelque chose qui est
indispensable
indispensable comme je vous l'ai dit en
introduction aussi dans l'application du
passeport qui est un outil extrêmement
utile utile pour améliorer l'efficacité
des contrôles on on boucle la boucle le
passeport permet de mieux cibler les
athlètes qui potentiellement ont des des
résultats normaux et donc de rendre le
système plus efficace et utile aussi au
regard de la diversité qu'on a sur la
planète aujourd'hui qui permet de tester
notamment des athlètes et de les suivre
quand ils viennent d'horizon ou
peut-être il est moins facile d'aller
les tester chez eux donc une utilité
globale et une utilité dans
l'amélioration du système alors voilà je
crois que aujourd'hui clairement il faut
pas baisser la garde l'affaire Armstrong
a monté la
sophistication avec laquelle les
tricheurs ceux qui veulent tricher
trichent et le message clair que nous
entendons régulièrement des athlètes
c'est protéger le sport et aider-nous à
pouvoir pratiquer ce qu'on aime notre
passion dans des conditions qui sont les
conditions dans lesquelles on aimerait
le faire Merci Merci à vous Monsieur C
oui ça va pas être long j'avais pas
prévu de remuer le passé mais comme
ériic l'a fait je vais moi aussi
témoigner de ce que j'ai vécu puisque
j'ai fait du foot à partir de 5 6 ans
jusqu'en étant professionnel à presque
38 ans donc c'est quand même un vécu
important dans cette discipline et
contrairement à Eric ben je me dis que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance énormément de
chance parce que ce qu'il me décrit là
me fait vraiment froid dans le dos
j'imagine ce qu'il a ce qu'il a enfin ce
que ce que les cyclistes ont dû et ont
pu subir je peux vous garantir que moi
en tout cas j'ai traversé ces
on va dire quoi ces 40 années dans le
dans dans le football sans jamais je
vous dis bien sans jamais avoir à penser
au dopage c'est énorme mais c'est c'est
j'ai prêté serment donc je vous le dis
comme je l'ai comme je l'ai
vécu ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui je plains mes collègues
actuels qui sont en activité qui
notamment pour ceux qui sont ciblés pour
ceux qui font partie justement des deux
qui sont désignés avec la
géolocalisation eux alors que
certainement bon on va pas on va pas va
dire qu'il y a pas de dopage dans le
foot c'est pas mes propos aujourd'hui
mais simplement sur l'aspect dans la
préparation dans le vécu de cette
carrière je me dis que pour ces un pour
ces ceses ces collègues là aujourd'hui
ils pensent au dopage tous les jours
voilà c'est c'est la petite le petit le
petit aparté que je voulais faire par
rapport à ce à ce passé maintenant vous
demandiez tout à l'heure à Serge s'il
avait des solutions ou des propositions
moi je vais me lancer parce que
justement pour finir j'en ai
quelques-unes on va marteler je vais
marteler ce que j'avais dit dans mon
dans mon préambule mais voilà il il y en
a quatre ou cinq il y en a cinq
exactement la première on demande à ce
qu'on mette un terme à la localisation
individuelle pour les disciplines
collectives c'est vrai que j'allais dire
heureusement cararmstrong était là ce
matin parce que je sais pas combien de
fois on a prononcé son nom mais il y a
eu pratiquement que lui hein qui a
focalisé et puis et puis illustrer cette
lutte contre le contre le dopage c'est
quand même assez significatif mais bon
voilà nous on demande en tout cas à ce
qu'on mette un terme à cette
localisation individuelle pour les
disciplines collectives remplacé c'est
ça la proposition par une localisation
collective à la charge de l'employeur
pendant la saison sportive puisqu'il est
le seul cet employeur à maîtriser
l'agenda de ses sportifs contrairement
au sport individuel ou en tout cas de la
plupart des sports individuels où
l'athlète gère son emploi du temps sauf
pendant les moments de compétition
lui-même c'est la grande différence avec
les sport co deuxièmement pour pour
illustrer c'était une des rares fois où
j'étais d'accord avec Monsieur Nigl ce
matin parce que bon j'aurais à dire sur
la représentativité des sportifs et
cetera mais ça va être trop long par
contre la préconisation de la à la FLD
elle est très importante elle est pas
respectée en France quand on parlait de
Zè des agences enfin des agences
nationales de lutte contre le dopage
seul pour être inclus dans le groupe
cible les sportifs choisis sur la base
de critères déterminés par le collège
scientifique de l'Agence française de
lutte contre le doopage pas par un
tirage au sort aléatoire et ce après une
évaluation adéquate des risques
pertinents sportifs blessés de longue
durée et ou sportifs dont les analyses
laissent planer un doute voilà ça c'est
les préconisations de laama reprise et
exprimé par la FIFA également qui est
quand même notre notre organe de de de
tutelle ensuite ce qu'on demande c'est
renforcer les contrôles antidopage
inopinés mais sur le lieu de travail
donc c'est complémentaire avec ma
première proposition et surt l'effectif
de manière très
aléatoire autant de fois que autant de
fois que c'est que c'est nécessaire on
demande également à ce que tout le monde
travaille avec les syndicats sportifs he
d'ailleurs je vous remercie à nouveau de
nous avoir de nous avoir convié ce matin
pour mettre en place des programmes
d'éducation et de prévention par parce
que ça ça a pas été évoqué hein c'était
pas l'objet de mais je crois qu'on est
on est nous très bien placé puisque
juste un petit chiffre monsieur nigli
quand vous parlez de représentativité
nous en tout cas au niveau des
footballeurs professionnels français 96
% des footballeurs Pro sont adhérents de
l'UNFP ça veut dire que justement que ce
soit la FNAS et on pourrait décliner ça
sur les sur les cinq autres syndicats on
est très représentatif on n'est pas
coopté on est élu par nos par nos par
nos joueurs par nos sportifs en une
activité et notamment vers les centres
de formation parce que là aussi on n pas
donneré de dimensions d'âge aujourd'hui
mais faisons ce travail très tôt hein et
pour les sports pro qui sont organisés
comme ça quand il y a des centres de
formation je pense qu'on est et on doit
mettre en place ce travail de
d'information et puis enfin s'assurer
mais c'est une minimum mais bon c'est
pas fait donc on le répète que le
travail demandé aux fédérations avec les
conventions d'objectifs hein qui partent
du qui partent du ministère en matière
de justement de prévention de lutte
contre le dopage soit bien rempli et
quand on parlait de gouvernance tout à
l'heure c'est vrai qu'on constate que
c'est pas le cas
merci
merci monsieur Simon allons-y monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
encore merci de cette invitation
évidemment une conclusion qui va
reprendre un petit peu le fil des propos
nous avons tenu le débat on été très
riche je vous en remercie j'ai vécu des
moments extrêmement intéressants
notamment quand monsieur nigli devient
devient porte-parole des
athlètes c'est des bons moments donc les
athlètes sont à vos côté monsieur N
monsieur castengers et et moi-même si
vous voulez des avis
euh des préconisations bien sûr j'en ai
monsieur euh monsieur Himbert elle elle
reprenent ce que j'ai dit en liminaire
et et ce débat n'a fait que nourrir mes
convictions euh il
faut permettre à la lutte antidopage de
ne pas s'exonérer de ses devoirs elle
engage des moyens très importants donc
elle doit rendre des comptes
d'efficacité d'évaluation permanente de
ces méthodes de ses moyens euh d'une
certaine transparence de ses objectifs
don un constat départ je reviens à ce
que j'ai dit en étant factuel c'est pas
un jugement de valeur c'est pas une
façon encore une fois de de s'échapper
de quoi que ce soit c'est simplement une
approche médicale c'est des c'est des
politiques de puissance publique qui
sont qui engagent énormément de moyens
et elle ne peut s'exonérer d'une
efficacité d'un bon sens de critique
alors la critique sur la géolocalisation
puisque moi j'en ai pas parlé je vais la
faire elle est elle est très simple euh
le kproco qui est à chaque fois amené au
devant de la discussion c'est comme si
Nous voulions Nous euh euh échapper à la
géolocalisation c'est ne pas savoir où
on est non c'est pas ça qu'on dit c'est
que nous on sait où on est donc vous
nous localiser très facilement
effectivement 11 mois de l'année 10 he
par jour vous savez où nous sommes si
vous savez pas acheter l'équipe au
milieu olympique pour le rugby et c'est
très simple à savoir où sont les
rugbyman et pas les 30 du groupe cible
les 1000 pro donc oui à la
géolocalisation mais par des méthodes
très simple très efficace et autant de
contrôle inopiné que que que vous voulez
c'est simplement un petit exemple sur
l'impossibilité d'évaluer une méthode ça
coûte de l'argent ça finit en tout cas
dans les rapports de la FLD il y a pas
de contrôle positif par la
géolocalisation il y a simplement de
nocho c'est important c'est des joueurs
qui ont été pour le coup on les connaît
c'est Yan qui est privé de Coupe du
monde les camarats qui a pris un an de
suspension un an de suspension pour pas
se dépatouiller d'un logiciel c'est on
marche sur la tête et on n pas le droit
de dire on' pas le droit de critiquer
donc oui je pense que une une des
préconisations c'est de mettre la lutte
antidempage devant ser devoir elle a des
droits elle a des devoirs et si elle a
des droits d'enfreindre des libertés
individuelles des lois pour tous les
autres citoyens faut vraiment qu'elle le
justifie encore plus donc ça c'est le
premier point deuxème point c'est sur le
fond de la lutte antiopage et
effectivement Sylvin euh de manière très
habile soulligne que euh un invité de
Marc était avec nous aujourd'hui c'est
Amstrong et je pense qu'il a dû être
présent à pas mal de de auditions aussi
euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
l'affaire
monsieur nigli le porte en éendard en
disant voyez c'est pour ça qu'il faut
une luite antidopage mais il la faire
Amstrong c'est la démonstration de la
faillite de la lutte antiopage comm elle
a organisé aujourd'hui c'est la
démonstration de son échec total et
qu'est-ce qui a fait tomber Armstrong
c'est pas des contrôles monsieur la
pouble rappelé c'est une c'est une
enquête administrative ça veut dire quoi
ça ça met en ça met en mot de manière
extrêmement concrète une piste qui est
très simple c'est que Eric raconta son
son son parcours dans le cyclisme tout
le monde sa sa c'estd se doper et encore
plus dans un sport collectif si le
doping arrive dans les sport C
évidemment ça va se savoir ça va se
savoir ça va se partager ça va des des
systèmes vont s'organiser et cetera et
cetera donc il y a des informations à
récolter avec ou sans contrôle urinaire
avec ou sans passeport biologique il y a
d'autres façons d'appréhender le
problème on est parti dans une voie et
on accélère de plus en plus il a je
pense qu'il y a d'autres méthode
effectivement de mettre de mettre fin à
ces phénomènes comme dans d'autres
pourquoi le sport se focaliserait sur la
biologie pour mettre en en en en en
évidence ou pour démontrer des
comportements il y a d'autres façons
d'enquêter administrativement et encore
une fois l'affaire Amstrong le prouve
des témoignages des saisis de disque dur
ça laisse des traces des protocoles
comme ça sur des mois et des mois et des
mois donc je pense qu'il y a énormément
d'autres pistes et non pas se focaliser
sur sur une voix qui montre des limites
en permanence et qui ces limites étant
démontrés à chaque fois par des échecs
ne fait qu'accélérer dans cette voie-là
franchissant encore une fois les lignes
une à une que nous dénonçons
c'est-à-dire infraction à liberté
individuelle et cetera et cetera et
cetera donc sortir de ce ce dogmatisme
mettre de la raison un côté factuel
libérer la parole parce que aussi cette
hyperpression médiatique cette espèce de
de de comment dirais-je d'inflammabilité
de ce sujet dès qu'on lève la main on
fait la Une on fait la une des journaux
fait qu'on peut pas on peut pas discuter
de il y a qu'ici parce que vous nous
l'obligez sous servement à parler ces
chosesl mais sinon c'est très difficile
il faut libérer la parole Armstrong il
est tombé parce que la parole s'est
libérée sous la contte mais elle s'est
libérée il faut libérer la parole et la
parole des athlètes des pratiquants il
faut pas les réifier nous ne sommes pas
des êtres spinaux monsieur nigli nous
avons un cerveau donc si on se met en
danger on peut aussi se protéger nous
sommes responsables il faut nous
associer les athlètes sont l'alpha et
l'oméga de la lutte en dopage c'est eux
qui prennent les produits c'est eux qui
vont être sanctionnés c'est eux qui se
mettent en danger c'est qui trichent
comment on peut ne pas les
associer mais factuellement dans la
lutte antidopage dans dans l'écoute de
ce qu'il faut mettre en place et cetera
donc il faut vous parliez de la
gouvernance mais encore plus dans
l'antidommage il faut que cette parole
des pratiquants soit entendu associé et
sortir encore une fois de cette
ambivalence qui est ouais mais le
sportif c'est d'abord un suspect oui ben
alors là on s'en sortira jamais
voilà
merci merci monsieur le Président
euh juste de trois petits points je
pense que je insister sur la question de
distinguer entre les amateurs et les
professionnels je pense qu'on peut pas
continuer à obliger les sportifs
amateurs à supporter les mêmes
obligations que pour les professionnels
j'en viens au professionnels je pense
qu'effectivement il serait bon que dans
les commissions disciplinaire fédéral
pour les professionnels il puisse y
avoir une représentation des
professionnels ça ça me paraît tout à
fait nécessaire pour qu'effectivement
puisse assurer la clarté des débats et
j'en viens à quelque chose c'està que
que vous avez entendu Christophe basson
et quand il a été traité quand il a été
traîné devant la l'Agence française de
lutte contre le dopage on a demandé on a
demandé une séance publique et moi
j'aimerais que si vous voulez que dans
les séances disciplinaires on est des
séances publiques parce que ça
permettrait on parlait de libérer la
parole ça permettrait d'éviter si vous
voulez les hondies les bouts de couloir
ça permet on joue la transparence c'est
malheureux qu'il est fallu attendre
cette année pour que la FLD pour la
première fois siège devant tout le monde
il y avait la presse en l'occurrence
mais peu importe et je pense que ça
c'est extrêmement important à ce propos
au niveau des sanctions qui sont prises
par les fédérations je souhaiterais qu'
au niveau du régime juridique une
unification je m'explique si la FLD ne
fait pas appel on va aller devant le
tribunal administratif du ressort de la
résidence du sportif concerné si la FLD
récupère le dossier on ira devant le
Conseil d'État moi je propose que la FLD
ou un autre organisme soit saisi de
l'ensemble des appels et qu'après ça
part directement devant le Conseil
d'État on aura une unification des
sanctions parce que là on a un système
où chaque fédération fait à près ce
qu'elle veut et après je vais lancer une
pierre dans le jardin du ministère
auquel j'ai appartenu je souhaiterais
que les statuts et les règlements soient
réellement relus j'ai pu assister avec
l'affire basson à des statuts d'une
fédération ou passez-moi excusez-moi du
peu monsieur le Président on avait quand
même la Fédération française de cyclisme
qui s'est attribué en lieu et place du
gouvernement le pouvoir réglementaire il
y a pas de décret c'est pas grave on
l'invente sauf que ce sauf que ce
règlement là été validé par le ministère
c'est quand même un vrai problème donc
soit le Ministère assure son contrôle
soit on dit qu'il assure pas de contrôle
et enfin j'en terminerai sur le rôle des
fédérations internationales alors je
suis désolé d'insister sur hon ça sera
l'exemple de la journée mais ça montre
bien que certaines fédérations
international fonctionne à l'envers
c'est-à-dire que effectivement la lutte
contre le dopage c'est pas leur problème
leur problème c'est d'éviter qu'on en
parle c'est d'éviter que les cas sortent
c'est le cas de l'UCI je suis pas
suffisamment naïf pour penser qu'il y a
que l'UCI qui soit dans cette dans cet
état d'esprit même si effectivement
c'est la seule à s'être fait prendre la
main dans le pot de confiture je vous
remercie de votre invitation et puis
j'espère que pouvoir lire rapidement les
conclusions de votre commission
d'enquête
merci nous arrivons 12h15 nous avons à
peu près tenu les les délais donc c'est
tout d'abord merci à vous d'avoir été
particulièrement efficace en peu de
mots travail va continuer nous allons
continuer à organiser des rencontres
nous allons essayer de travailler sur un
complément à apporter au texte existant
c'est le petit rôle des parlementaires
c'est aussi pour cela qu'il y a cette
commission mais en attendant c'est cette
période où nous aurons à réviser ou à
compléter la loi madame messieurs merci
merci beaucoup pour votre participation
pour votre franchise et pour un certain
nombre d'éléments je crois me souvenir
je réponds à une question qui n'était
pas
posée que le rapporteur et moi-même
n'avons à aucun moment cité le nom de l
ang comprennent qui
pourra mais bon merci à
vous